Those are gooner game apparently.
Wait, you're willing to go on YouTube for Min but not for
me?
Hi guys!
Oh no no no no no no no no no no.
You're a bad boy.
Boom!
Right now, Doki is getting upset at Lai-Mu for watching me
on YouTube and not watching her.
I'm trying to go for Twitch streams if I can because I
should learn how to use it.
And I was saying that I watched Lai-Mu playing Assassin's
Creed recently.
Hey, Min's playing Dave the Diver and I'm like, oh go on my
girl.
Like in everything.
It's like 70 games in a trench coat.
The DLC is insane.
It's so.
It's so good.
So it pretends to be a sushi restaurant and diving game.
But then it's like, oh, but then there's actually, you know,
you get the Yakuza DLC and now it's a side scrambling
beat-em-up.
Yeah, you get the Godzilla DLC and you can fight Kaijus.
And then you get like...
If you get the jungle DLC, you can do like...
Everything.
It's Animal Crossing.
And RPG.
And then there's like an Animal Crossing.
crossing bit and then there's actual fishing fishing it's
great i haven't gotten to fishing fishing fishing my brother
is really upset that we considered marvel rivals not a
gooner game by the way they're not i mean it is a little
it's a gooner it's like it's like it's like a bonus it's
just like a little like dessert you know the last thing i
saw about marvel rivals was someone made a fan skin for
jubilee and people thought it was real and her lips were
like all the way out Which ones?
People just believe that was real.
Because of it being the one you're thinking about.
Am I missing out?
It's the one you're thinking about.
Which lips?
I mean, think about it, chat.
Think about, but like, what, you're not actually missing out
because it's third person, so you're seeing the backside.
So it's like the enemy team, if they have the same mod, they
get, they get to have the.
no it's they get to enjoy enjoy it do they make i don't
think i can i don't think i can look for it yes there's like
a translation mod wait i'll show you what it's true i've
seen so many people with the uh with the luna one what let's
see character models which which one is it actually i think
i have to like go into like the mod thing and then and then
be like yes i'm over 18 before i could see it did you say
inflation that you like accidentally put up when you were
when we were playing left for dead and you had like a mod
that had nudity in it and we didn't realize until the game
started or something oh that was who who was that that was
no it was it was snuffy i think i definitely like like a
furry i don't know if it was luna or like a character but
they had like nipple whipple i think is she like you know
like calling herself out move like did you okay or did you
get away with it i got away with that wait so like nothing
happened no no don't tell them about my go live notification
today either don't nobody no snitches in snuffie's chat no
wait what is it though no no snitch yeah but what is it you
can snitch to us don't worry my my streams muted yeah my
streams muted not even live i'm not even I'm not, yeah,
yeah, I turned on my stream just for this.
I'm really holding the power of just like messaging
everybody's phone, like a little buzz.
So you're just like, you maybe wait, maybe you're from
Europe and you're just waking up and you get like, oh, oh,
what's that?
You know, you open up your phone, the screen lightens up,
your eyes are just unfogging and you just see, dick's been
hard for six years.
Oh.
Happy birthday.
to my to my sound guys is the discord audio better sorry i
think we're gonna say is the discord audio actually muted
yeah yeah yeah so i am muted just now i am muted just now
you say to your sound guys like like am i hey on the set
here on the set we're the sound guys like the live band did
you get it guys all right guys did you get the one all right
all right let's cut next scene yeah everybody snuffy was
just acting and scene and Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
You promised my life.
This menu is really gross, by the way.
It's so nasty.
The actual text is terrible.
I'm still trying to find a Luna Inflation Mine.
Oh, please.
I'm surprised you don't have like a hotkey for it.
I know, right?
I'm surprised too.
There's like, I'm like, I'm messing with the menu.
I'm messing with the menu and like there's just a setting
here that just says feel.
It says feel feel smooth.
Oh, it's like my options are smooth and low latency.
So I'm gonna assume that's mouse acceleration I'm having to
interpret it Maybe I'm turning it.
I'm turning it to low latency to be fair like it's so hard
to read this.
It's like ye old Yeah, are you can you read?
Are you okay?
What do you mean?
The ye old the fight The music's fucking awful as well.
It's just going
muted for a bit all right let's see maniacal strings and
i'll put it in the i'll put in the hangout chat okay so this
is like a video oh you finally you've been searching for it
this whole time i never i didn't lie i was very transparent
what i was doing uh whoa whoa
wow wow I don't think I can share that with my chat.
I'm just good.
I'm just gonna move on There's an invisible woman one by the
way I am but I got a little distracted your hitbox.
Yeah, no, no, it's just it's cosmetic for yourself Oh, if
you if you play with that you just basically like fuck
yourself up because half of well over half of that model is
not actually the hitbox Right.
Okay.
Yeah, you can't see So if you're playing with it, you can't
see it.
Nice, nice.
Because that's like the dedication to it, though, yeah.
It's covering like one third.
Let me find the invisible woman one.
You could have sent that to me and I would have just
believed that's what she looked like.
I've never seen this.
You're like, oh, that's what I'm curious, dude.
Like that.
Yeah.
Honestly.
Honestly, I won't be surprised.
Why do you guys want me to link it?
They're like, I want to, Did you want fact check you just be
like is it the right mod you know Oh, okay, so it's it's
code joining by the way, so don't capture until we've uh Oh,
is it?
I'm like in the air.
I made the lobby.
Oh, you did?
It says you can it says join with code here.
So maybe there's a code somewhere on your menus.
Oh my god, where am I?
Yeah, it does say join with code.
Where am I?
I'm at simulation.
There's a where am I?
Where am I?
simulation you're the one who wanted to play this yeah
because i saw where is this place i don't know where i am
i'm in like a simulation room i'm about to start a lobby so
i can help you okay wait i found it oh my god you found it
okay it's like phasophobia coded like the oh like you have
to yeah you're the main lobby oh okay so there's like tier
one crew apparently it's like a rogue like too i'm having
fun listening to these maniacal strings i'm trying to find
it I feel like I'm being thriller chased at the finale of a
movie.
Oh, I found...
Wait.
I can't stop looking at the meat.
Okay, my thing is, like, we're friends only.
So, like, even if the...
Okay, apparently there is a code right in front of you, but
I don't know where it is right now.
Wait, so does that mean chat saw the code?
They might have saw the code, but they can't join because
they have to be my esteem friend.
Oh.
Yeah.
Okay.
Is it this?
But that's just this burger?
No, that's not...
code the super secret code i'm gonna i'm gonna make my own
lobby and if i find the code before you i'm gonna make my
own lobby with blackjack and strippers who can make the who
can buy the code oh my god yeah yeah yeah yeah okay i'm
looking burger by burger we shall listen no it's actually so
trippy like i'm like where the am i right now joining my own
oh this is confusing as i'm not I told you.
I'm not gonna show chat.
Why is there a head on the desk?
I'm showing chat right now.
There's blackjack?
Wait, we can gamble?
Wait, there's actual blackjack?
I'm looking for room code.
Doki's getting distracted.
You're gonna lose the speedrun.
Oh my god, there's Uma Musume.
There's Uma Musume in the lobby.
What are you?
I just think you're fucking lying, man.
You're just making shit up.
You're making shit up.
There's like, why are you like this?
First it, first it was the face.
Put the diarrhea conspiracy.
The water sheds and the frogs gay.
What does that have with it?
What are you talking about?
I'm obsessed with how I define this lobby.
King's place sucks.
There is a... Oh, there's a kitchen over here.
There is... There's an arcade.
It's not... There's literally an arcade here.
How are you supposed to pick stuff up?
And then there's the Paragon?
What is Baluga?
Where am I?
I don't know, man.
Wait, where's the code?
Wait, why is it- It's too dark to find the code!
It's so fucking dark!
You can turn your flashlight on.
Can I just like- wait, can I just invite you to game?
Wait, you can just invite people to game!
No, fine, we gotta find the code, guys!
We gotta give you- Just invite people to game!
Because they expect you to use the Steam friends.
I don't- I don't freaking see no code.
No, neither do I.
There's a chiropractic massage area.
They're like, let me invite you guys.
All right.
No, I'm looking for the code.
I'm going to find it.
I'm going to find, not if I find it first.
Why is this place so huge?
There's no code.
There has to be a code.
There's no way.
The code is a lie.
There is a code.
You guys are just not looking hard enough.
You're not really good at looking.
I mean, you've been in here longest.
No, I've just been chilling.
I was like, I was gambling.
Oh, I'm in the simulation, yeah.
Yeah, see, I told you.
There's a closet here.
There's like, there's like my own room and everything.
I'm not seeing Uma Musume.
Have I been invited yet?
Oh, okay, so you go to the simulation and turn and...
I fell into a hole into hell.
And then there's the training.
There's the prepare, the vessel.
Oh, that's me.
I also fell into hell.
Yeah, I know that when I died.
It was right by burger.
Ready up.
Guys, I don't...
Oh, I'm in hell.
I'm in hell.
How are you getting help?
Simulation unstable.
Oh wait, I'm in the simulation.
There's a training area.
Doki, have you sent any invites out yet?
Have we ever played the game?
Did you invite us to the game?
Yeah, I sent out an invite.
Just now, just now.
No, someone was not accepting my invite, so that's not on
me.
I still don't have an invite.
I'm back to the cold embrace of the menu.
Um, oh, I invited somebody to watch me play.
It doesn't show you're in game, by the way.
So you might not be able to invite us.
I clicked it.
You, you, you, you played me like a fiddle.
I'm clicking on this.
I'm waiting for Doki Birds broadcast to start.
I can't watch my stream.
I was waiting for my invoice.
I click watch.
You just, you just catfished me.
my stream wait i got an invite yeah getting invited getting
and joining a game is a looking achievement because of how
hard it is i hear voices i hear voices get out wait are you
guys there in game should we use in game boys i'm leaving
the game you're guys just getting am i in this game wait
send me another invite please well i was in my game since
i'm in the game
Wait, I sent...
No, I'm another invite.
You know she's here.
Christ, please, please.
Thank you.
Wait, are we using in-game audio?
You want in-game or Discord?
You know what?
Let's just...
I don't know how good is the proximity.
I feel like proximity noise is always...
One second!
What did you do?
Hello?
Oh my god, we're all over here!
Alright, guys, you know the drill.
It's time to turn down.
the squid audio oh okay okay oh i already deafened because
my brain was like rattling let's see hold on all right i
need to write this down i don't want to do that do i just
like mute my oh my god look at this no you just lower it on
oh wait i can't think live on those all right just mute
ourselves we're muting okay okay i i already deafened a
while ago is that okay yeah i know yeah no it's fine wait
what oh my you you are horrifying hello we're all horrifying
flying this is how we were
mince over here i heard mint earlier i think she might have
been right back because she's gone very still oh i heard her
earlier yeah yeah she's here she's here real fast so i'm
tabbing out i'm tabbing out so we don't i won't be able to
hear you guys okay all right sound gap sound team is
everything okay i'm using i will be able to acknowledge your
stuff because i can't mute in this game wait no push your
talk might work hold on Oh, she's having a wasp problem.
Oh, she spilled her tea.
All right, let's see.
Let me turn.
I'll turn up the game audio, too.
Wait, can you guys say something?
Something.
Well, that's Duffy, because we can't hear her.
Can you hear me now?
Yeah, hello?
Oh, I'm- Did you cough on me?
Somebody coughed on me.
My character did.
That's kind of weird.
Can you just- I'm trying not push to talk.
If you can hear me after, like, I say now, Let me know now.
You think she heard you?
All right, I'm...
So Snuffy is...
Yeah, Mint's getting attacked by a wasp, and Snuffy's, like,
a mute.
So that's unfortunate.
Snuffy, rejoin!
Rejoin the room, Snuffy!
I heard it for, like, one second, too.
Is she, like...
Stop spitting at me!
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna fix my audio real quick, too.
I'm gonna turn it up a little bit more.
Were you guys able to hear everybody earlier?
Or was it too quiet?
I'm in.
Hi.
Oh.
Maybe when I Discord crashed, like my settings also got
reset.
I don't know.
Did I ever sound sounded good earlier on Discord?
Like before we got in-game voice?
All right.
That's cool.
discord up a lot though when what about like when before
sound guy told me to up discord because i had to up it a lot
let me oh whoops oh no i fucked up oh no maybe try yeah can
you hear us nothing all right there you go all right all
right are we all good oh snuffy has to rejoin all right wait
how do you how do you chat rejoin we will invite re we will
i like that chat is usually the same button so you can
figure it out yeah t yeah it's usually either t or y in
games you can or you hit enter oh yeah oh man you're so
quiet huh am i good oh never mind he's not quiet she's just
mumbling i'm gonna Muberland?
Alright, let me invite her.
Wait, Min, I shoved you and the cloud of air came out like
brown.
Why would it do that?
Concerning.
It's because she doesn't shower.
No, I do shower.
She's covered in like...
Take a bath.
Okay, it says you.
What's that?
How do you shove?
R.
Oh, if you know.
Oh, I see the brown coming from...
Let's see.
Let's see if it comes from Dukie Bird.
I bet so, I bet so.
Yeah, there it is.
Wow, a huge, huge cloud.
Yeah, it came out because I touched you.
Wow, it's because I touched you.
So you infected me with this.
You couldn't even touch me.
You could barely, no.
Oh, yeah?
Bam.
What's that, huh?
Yeah, boom.
Oh, there's so much brown.
It's so much brown.
You just spit on me, too.
Oh, she needs another.
How about all of us invite it?
All right, we all invite Snepi and then see who she joins.
Dynamo, invite Stuffy.
Okay.
Wait, how do you invite her, though?
You just click on the arrow and invite.
Steam invite.
Oh, that way.
I thought it was in-game.
Yeah, we all invite her.
Oh, she's back.
She connected after I hit invite.
I just want to point that out.
Snuffy.
Ooh, she hates Doki.
No, it's because apparently it didn't work at first.
Snuffy!
Oh, there she is!
We heard her for like one second, too.
Have you checked the audio settings?
I mean, they're pointing to the right microphone and
everything.
Well, she can't hear us, though.
I think she can, though.
I think she can hear us.
She just said she was having trouble because she was tabbing
out to try and fix it.
And she was like losing audio.
Oh.
Can you hear us?
us how do you spit oh wait she can hear us wait look at the
audio setting look at the go to options go to sound and then
there's push to talk off yeah try that just double click we
heard you for one second stuffy so some you were you were
with us for one second just push that on enough
and then change your mic settings dude go to options set i
feel like i'm like sorry i don't know why i'm speaking loud
sorry go to the one below push to top and then adjust your
mic settings and just play around over until we hear you the
guy heard stop spitting at her she can't even respond it's
just bullying oh sorry I'm meant to spit at you.
She doesn't know.
Wait, I have an idea.
Have you fully restarted the game?
Wait, have you restart?
No, she's restarted.
I don't think you start a PC.
It will work.
You have a weird microphone set up, Snuffy.
Do you have a weird microphone?
We could make it, we could just do a mute, and then she'll
talk to us via Discord.
Yeah.
We could, we could just all.
We'll use Discord, to be honest, as well, if we need to.
No, no, we can just do a mute, and then she'll talk to us on
Discord.
Okay.
She'll be, like, the omnipresent.
Presence.
Alright.
I'm mute.
I'm undefeating, but putting on mute.
Alright.
Snuffy, say something.
Why does he talk to myself on Discord?
Oh, I can hear you.
Wait, Doki and Limo are muted, though.
Wait!
Are we talking?
Wait.
Oh, I get it.
You guys are talking to her on Discord.
Wait, I can't hear you guys now.
I can't hear you.
Oh, I turned the voices down.
He doesn't want to hear the voices anymore.
Alright, guys, you didn't believe, like, come with me, come
with me, I'll show you the arcade.
Come with me, you guys didn't believe me.
It's right here.
Okay, so you guys can't hear me, right, though?
Yeah, yeah, I can hear you.
Look, look, blackjack!
I'm sorry, I don't know why it wasn't working.
It's blackjack, and then Uma Musa-man.
Wait, actually.
I can't, nobody's like, man.
Just like, future horse racer.
Gonna win it all.
How do I queue it up?
I believe in free sample.
Buy in $25, man.
Increase me.
No, we have no cash.
We don't.
We gotta make money.
So we can gamble.
All right, guys.
So we gotta go work our day job so we can gamble, I guess.
Do we go down into the dip with the hell pit?
Is that...
That's the simulation.
Don't touch that.
That don't touch this.
I'll play you.
I'll jump.
Oh yeah.
I'll play you.
Is it dressed as a cow?
He's dressed as a cow.
I got it.
There it is.
Oh I got it.
Oh I don't have any adopted.
I got it.
Okay wait.
No no.
I'm going to- oh.
Oh wait, you're so close.
Wait wait.
Thread the needle.
What are you guys playing?
Oh no no hold on.
Give me one second.
I'll hit it.
Oh, you guys?
Oh, are you guys free?
You're hockey?
Just around the room, around the room.
No!
Oh!
Wait, did you get a point?
Did it go then?
I got a point.
It says, it says- Oh, it says one!
It says one!
No!
It's a ghost!
There's a ghost!
You're taking over my game!
Yeah!
Stop!
This is a fair game!
Oh, oh, come on, come on, come on, so close.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, oh, yeah!
You just sabotaged me!
You sabotaged me!
You got a gift.
That was a gift from God!
I didn't do anything!
It's the hand of God!
What's this one?
How do we play this game?
Let me know if it's better.
Oh, that's just pool.
It's just pool.
It's like we're in the VR chat world right now of all the
memes.
It does feel like that.
Oh.
My bad.
Oh, there's a soda.
I'll take one.
a bump cola oh oh that was art to throw i swear these games
that you find i get like overstimulated within about 30
seconds of joining the lobby it's true it's true every good
game has has a basketball now are you guys ready to work our
day jobs getting buzzed and throwing balls down to paradise
oh i see so we just our chill area and then we actually go
down to hell to work i see can i hold There is a training
section over here.
I look like the cool kid at summer camp.
We don't need a train.
Okay, down into hell then.
I'm ready.
We're going to hell?
Okay.
Oh, okay.
All right.
Can I just queue up?
Queuing up?
Oh, I think I died.
Did you fall into the pit?
Oh, we...
Yay!
We're in the pit!
We're being...
Bagungas.
That's sad.
It's really boring to be fast food workers.
okay all right all right this looks like five nights of
buddies what is that thing though your locks your legs
brings me drops the stability falls oh this is the roguelike
part where we can upgrade so we can upgrade our stuff okay
yeah so this is this is like overcooked but gross maybe but
we'll work for money oh you can hire in people to help you
out but we don't have any oh my god they got peter griffin
the game nothing in stock i'm not gonna shop money love toe
his name is toe toe okay i guess i guess we just start the
simulation then dude i drink so much and you guys sound like
robots i'm stuck in how do we choose a contract help oh we
have to choose one of these oh wait there was a good one and
you picked the bad one oh well it's all right here we go
It's all right.
We're good.
Wait, there's already an order.
There's already an order you guys.
Oh my god Wait, we have 50 seconds.
What is happening?
Jesus.
Oh, yeah, I like how the game was like you get a free close
out though He's like no, I don't want to be able to run
today Jungle Cola freeze.
We need one Jungle Cola freeze with a peppery blast You're
speaking worse than I don't know.
I have a soft.
I have a soft We don't need to train.
It'll be fine.
We can do this.
We we're good Wait, where even is all that?
Oh, those are all just drinks.
I found jungle cola freeze.
I just got a jungle cola freeze.
Are they like...
Oh, peppery breasts?
I got it.
What did he want?
What do you...
Where do I deliver it to him?
Peppery breasts.
They're all drinks.
I found pepper.
Excuse me, ma'am.
I need to pick that up.
Okay, wait.
What do we do?
Swimmers choice?
What is that?
That's another drink.
He's on drinks.
I have the jungle cola freeze.
I have that, but where do I give it to?
Collect it must be here, right?
Separate breasts.
It must be there.
Pop on pot sauce, pickles, vegan, chicken potty, lettuce and
buns.
Are we gonna be okay?
Who's making the burgers?
Yes?
How can I help you?
She doesn't want burger.
I just got drinks.
I'm so confused.
I'm so confused as to what I'm looking at and what I'm
doing.
Nobody's making a burger.
I'm gonna make a burger.
Where's the grill?
You don't need a burger.
It's just drinks.
It's peppery breast.
Peppery breast is not a drink.
Yeah, peppery breast is a...
Where's the grill?
Oh, it's a drive-thru too.
What is the grill?
I wanted to do the tutorial!
Oh, this is a grill.
The tutorial was before the screen.
I was setting up.
I didn't even notice it.
There was also training.
There was training.
Bottom bun.
What the fuck is this?
I need lettuce.
Where's the order at?
I need to tell what each menu item is.
I'll go outside and entertain the crowd.
Hello, hello.
Can I only have you with?
I think that's all.
Hello?
Okay.
How do I know what it's doing better?
Bottom bun.
Luscious.
Can I get a burger?
Chicken patty.
I think we need a chicken patty.
How do you make a chicken patty?
We put the BRG and the other R burger.
Okay, I need the rest.
Bacon times two.
Sorry, I worked here.
My bad.
I have two beacons here.
They go in there.
Pop them on, pop them on.
Where do you see the order at?
Oh, we need the chicken then.
We need the chicken first, Nuffie.
Oh, okay.
I think it's okay.
I don't know when it's ready.
Chicken patty.
No, neither do I.
That's the way that's a bun bottom.
That's not a chicken.
That's bun bottom
You were growing a burger bun
What's happening am I dying?
That's a chicken.
That's no chicken Wait, what's in there?
Oh, this is cookies.
Where's the chicken?
It's ice.
Okay, we got oh this is Chicken!
This is the chicken!
Right here!
I got a bug on them.
Oh, I found it!
I found it!
I found the chicken!
We found it!
We did it!
The order expired!
Someone was not looking very well.
It was right here.
Wait, hold on a second.
The jungle cola freeze and the peppery breast is so good.
Oh my god.
I got the... I got the... I got the chicken breast.
I'm doing it.
The grill's on fire!
How can I help?
help you oh grows on fire you need to come closer oh no
pickles pickles pickles i'm i'm making my burger right now
is there anything to prevent fire safety what is that i
think i think hot sauce and a top one excuse me i got i got
the burger i made the burger the fire is getting worse when
does it become a problem uh how do you think the freezer
we're putting it out where's the the building has become the
cook itself we're on oh there's the fire okay yeah from hell
we're fine okay okay okay don't give her a soul to the
customer no thank you nice agent orange and deep sea sammy
agent orange i got it i got it we need a fish a freezer
burst open can somebody grill us a fish a freezer a freezer
yeah i got you poor do the tutorial i hate you it was
limeu's suggestion not to yeah i hate you too because limeu
wants us to like wants to look so good in front of I got the
Agent Orange.
Okay, I got the fish patty.
Where do we put the fish patty?
I think it's done.
What's a deep sea Sammy?
Where do you put it on?
It's done.
I don't know.
Oh, you did it?
You made it?
Oh, a bag.
Nice.
Some of our choice.
I think we're doing really good.
Agent Orange.
Okay, I found the recipe for a deep sea Sammy.
I need a fish patty.
Is that it?
That's it?
I got it Snobity The wrong order There was a Sammy A Sammy
and a drink I didn't know it was the wrong burger How do you
take it out?
I got the fish patty I got the fish patty Dude he got an
order And he's still waiting He just wants a free order I
mean we could fuck up his order I'm getting the agent one I
mean the order is still there Nobody's really What the fuck
Why is there just a frozen piece of fish On my desk sorry
manager it's cooked okay that's that's that's not how that
works oh shit I don't know what's mean is we're with so we
gotta figure this out what do you mean you're the only
reliable one yeah you're the reliable one I need more fish I
have a fish I got fish cooked right here okay slap that fish
on the burger i'm forming i'm we have two minutes to make
one burger no the timer's going up it's going up oh yeah
yeah for every job well done we do it goes up i did it i
mean it's my second rule put it in there put it in there
could someone please put that thing on the burger oh you got
him you got him
One burger!
Can I get a...
Wait, hold on, I got it.
Oh, I can do it.
I'm gonna do it.
I got this.
Agent, Agent Orange, Jungle Cola Freeze, I have so many
patties.
And a mother clucker.
There you go.
Thank you.
Alright, we have... Mother clucker.
Is that the... I have a chicken right here.
Wait, is this a chicken or is this a chicken?
I got all the drinks, baby.
I've got that.
God, that's complicated.
Are you making it over there then?
I don't know.
I got the chicken right here.
I just want to be useful.
What's the other thing?
Ancient.
Jungle cola freeze.
Thank God you don't have to cook the bacon.
Chicken.
Is this chicken?
I don't know what this is.
It's cooked beef.
Cook chicken.
This is the chicken.
Have you put the chicken on?
Yeah.
And then cheese, tomatoes.
I got chicken here.
Tomato.
Order up.
How do you do the, uh, Oh, the cups.
Oh, yeah, you just grab them.
I already did the drinks, though.
Mayo hot sauce.
Pop one second, man.
Mother clucker.
One mother clucker hot off the gritty.
Is it in there?
Yeah.
It's in there.
We hit our first quota!
Dairy fairy.
You're doing such a good job.
Wait, what's a dairy fairy?
Oh, shit.
What the heck is a dairy fairy?
What is a dairy fairy?
Oh, I found it.
What is that?
G-Greep?
G-Greep!
What is it?
And peppery breast.
Why am I spooked?
I'm scared.
Am I, am I, am I fried?
I don't know what's going to happen.
Wait, hold on.
Do we, do, should we leave the simulation before it breaks
apart?
Is that what we should do?
We can make, do the quota met.
Because there's a quota met lever here.
Oh.
Yeah, there you go.
Your shift is ended, get the hell out of there.
Ah, it's a fire!
Fire everywhere!
Ah!
Guys, guys, do you remember where we live?
Where's the...
Is this it?
Where did we...
We're here, here!
Is he alright?
We live here.
Yes, here, it's here.
Hey, why are we living in a simulation?
But I think we have to do the objectives.
I think we have to do the objectives.
We did!
Oh my god, we didn't close the restaurant.
We didn't close.
We didn't lock the doors.
Yeah, we need to close.
Oh, we need to extinguish the fire!
objectives oh my god the trash disposal don't worry about it
I'll do the trash I got the trash I have no idea where's all
the fucking fire extinguishers gone I got one okay I got one
hey hey someone's getting trash Kobe okay I think the fires
are done yeah this trash what is this oh we got to restock
the kitchen I've heard like a demon.
I think there's a demon here.
Oh, no.
Oh, there is a demon.
Does he want some cheese?
There is indeed a demon.
Where does the cheese go?
Oh, maybe here.
There's a demon.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, ignore what Doki said earlier.
Fuck the demon.
Have you respect Limo?
How do you do this?
Oh, my God.
We have found it.
What do I have right now in my hand?
Me?
Is that kind of bacon?
This is not productive.
Is anybody alive?
I'm alive.
Okay.
I got all the fires.
Maybe I should leave.
I'm leaving.
I hope I hope.
I hope we can leave.
Can we leave?
Are we safe in here?
I don't know, man.
I guess we should do the whole thing.
I'm just gonna...
No!
Not me!
Oh, my God.
Oh, wow.
What is so scary.
I didn't... I thought the...
I thought cooking was perfect.
He was hard.
Oh my God!
What happens now?
Is this like Luigi wins by doing nothing?
Wait!
Why did they get- Why did they get brought back to the
live?
I'm employee of the week!
Oh, of the week.
Guys, I was stuck on my tablet.
I think I've grown some focus on my body now.
Who's up there?
There was a tutorial right here.
I think we should do the tutorial.
Yeah, I think we got it now.
I'm smoking from this burger bomb before we do the tutorial.
I got to enter my shift Yeah, does it do anything?
All right, let's step you're you're on fire.
It's just like it just like so you can familiarize yourself
with it a little bit I have a five minute sauce and things
like that.
Yeah, I drank some beer.
I pre I'm gonna smoke too Oh, oh my god, wait, there's
clothes.
I can be naked.
I can jump even higher.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, there should be a broom for us to like clean
this.
Wait, okay.
I don't have any sort of...
I've never done anything in my life.
Cat noises.
I could be Burger Chan.
Burger Chan.
Or the sock?
Yeah, is there a mop?
Oh, is there a mop?
It should be.
I think I guess not in the tutorial.
Fuck it.
You don't even see a tutorial.
Whoa, what's happening in there?
Oh, it's greasy.
I can't.
like a spilled drink so you can am I just that high or am I
stuck in the corner there's an unstuck wait is there there's
a bottom right there's an unstuck thing oh my god this guy
has like dirty ass this guy too these mannequins are not
well taken care of spit on it's stuffy I was cleaning that I
was doing spit shine is lime okay where's that oh it gets on
him doing the tutorial Eww!
Eww!
Wait, how do you do the tutorial?
Lymu.
Lymu is locked in.
She was taken.
I think it's training and that you can just familiarize
yourself.
The tutorial is the thing we skipped at the start.
I watched it.
I think this is just like, you know, get used to like the
mechanism of making things.
Yeah, I watched it, but it was kind of confusing.
You know what, guys?
I think we know what we're doing now.
I think we can go into another shift.
honestly are you guys ready I just I think I think the thing
we're gonna struggle with is I don't know how to clock out
like properly we do all the objectives and then we're good I
think right yeah I guess so should we should we be all on
discord because it's kind of weird like only being able to
hear some people and then other people aren't fading out
it's actually that's true you guys can't drink in here how
fun you sound when you're buzzed I didn't hear any different
No, I heard it.
I see I heard the robot.
Oh, I see.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Whoa.
What just happened?
You press I'm stuck.
You get TP'd.
Oh, I was wondering what it did.
So are we switching to Discord then?
Welcome back to Discord.
Okay.
I think it makes more sense because it's kind of like...
Hello.
I'm on Discord.
I love me too.
I love this.
Uh, funny...
Sound gas!
Audio, audio adjusts everything again.
I'm trying.
But someone is not...
Oh, you're still open mic mint.
Yeah, you'll need to put it on...
You'll need to put it on push to talk then.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So that we kind of hear it in game.
Yeah, I don't see a thing that says, like, clock out.
So I feel like maybe we just do the objectives.
I feel like we hit the lever and then do the objectives and
then run to the...
Then run, yeah.
Or something, yeah.
There might be like a thing that we have to press after we
run in or something.
Guys, are you guys ready to go in?
Clock yes.
Yes.
Let's do it, we got this!
We got this!
I believe!
Are we clocked in?
I can't tell.
Oh, I'm coming down.
I think it like waits for everyone to get in there.
My bad.
Where do we go?
I'm lost.
I'm scared.
Where do you mean we're in hell?
Where did Snuffy?
Oh my god, I just see Snuffy exploring the lobby.
I didn't know I had to queue up.
Where do I go?
Yeah, jump in the hell.
Jump in the hell.
Take two.
The first one was a warm-up.
We're fine.
Burger by burger, we shall ascend.
Yeah.
Now we know where things are.
Those popping noises were like in the back of my brain.
B2.
That was scary.
the contract i okay you don't even know what's happening you
can only see this modifier kitchen over the glitches never
stop paranormal disturbance well both of those suck but i
feel like the mayhem would be worse because we already don't
know what we're doing i can jump higher because i smoked a
cigarette no what's happening shall we choose that oh all
right all right we're ready oh maybe this is where we clock
out oh i i'm another wonderful babe i'm on burger duty B we
got one little one little B one little B I probably need to
like collaborate on burger stuff because the orders aren't
that complex all right I'm grilling burgers yeah I'm
grilling burgers for us salmon nuggets swimmers choice all
right burger stuff is here I got the swimmer's choice fish
is done okay little b is really really simple can I do a
little b please okay you do the the kitchen manager all the
way there it's raw it's freaking raw they're all cooked
right here this one's raw it says not this one the one's
here they're right there there isn't anything there you've
thrown them into the freaking thing it doesn't show up
anymore i've got one now i've got one now my bad we got the
little b i get some cheese i'm getting the little b on
little b almost ready we'll be almost ready trap little b
little b put her in the bag put her in the bag yep there she
is it's in the bag the grill is on fucking fire kitchen
manager here kitchen manager i got it out of the way limu
put the b in the bag i put the b in the bag do we have a
salmon nuggets and the swimmer's choice okay we need salmon
nuggets we need the salmon nuggets who's got salmon nuggets
uh i don't know i'm gonna make Nuggies.
I just know how to mix meat.
It's supposed to be in here, right?
What's a salmon nugget?
Swimmer's choice is a drink, apparently.
Yeah, I already got that.
It's in there.
Yeah, we need salmon nugget.
Salmon nugget.
I'm going to put stuff... I'm going to start putting me on
the floor because it doesn't matter.
Nugget?
Okay.
Nothing matters.
Yeah, salmon nugs.
It's under fried food.
This is pie.
Where's the food, though?
Yeah, where do you find it?
Salmon nuggy, salmon nuggy.
I don't know.
I'm doing my job.
What is this raw pie tray?
Nope.
That's not what I want.
Um, I love.
Fries.
And we found the salmon nuggets.
I found the nuts.
We have nuts.
You did?
Where are the nuts?
Oh, they're under the fries.
Okay.
Oh, I'm cooking them.
I'm cooking them.
I'm making more patties.
I'm doing my job.
Oh, oh, these take a while.
Oh, my God.
Doki, why is there meat all over the floors?
Because it doesn't matter because you Guys, I see you can't
find me!
I see.
Are they almost done?
Is this on?
Oh, now it's on!
Kitchen manager here.
Okay, we don't have help inspectors.
It's just a simulation.
Wait, is it done?
I need to boost up the audio a little bit.
It looks like it's on.
It looks pretty, pretty toasty.
Doki's audio guy.
Yeah, can you suck my cot?
Oh my god!
Where are the salmon nuggets?
Oh, they're cooking, but they're not!
Oh, they're done!
They're done!
Yes!
They're both done!
Put the nugs in the thing!
Boom!
Yeah, serve it, serve it.
Yes!
All right.
Agent Orange.
Because it doesn't matter!
It doesn't matter!
Swimmers choice.
Is that another?
Oh my god.
There's simulations.
They're not real.
You are going to clean this all up when we close or you are
fired.
That is insane.
You have ruined this business.
Which one are you getting?
It's Agent Orange in there.
Okay.
I'll get the swimmer's choice.
I take my job very seriously.
Is it done?
You have to do the ice first.
Oh, ice first.
Yeah, yeah.
There you go.
Agent Orange.
Okay.
In the bag.
All right.
Who's doing the burger?
burger burger burger burger burger burger oh burger burger
is bottom bun sheep patty i got the big patty right here i
just had like a man talk to me did anybody else talk yeah i
heard that just the paranormal activities don't worry about
it i'm making that burger burger oh there is paranormal
activity look the chairs are floating did you put the
lettuce on before the cheese i don't think you is there
lettuce on there dokey stop that yes stop littering stop
littering in our yard.
This is the most uncertain I've ever heard you sound.
If I look at the screen that lists everything, is it going
to say lettuce on it?
Yes.
How do we raise the world from the ghost?
Is it going to say lettuce on it as I'm looking at it in
real time?
Don't put lettuce on anything.
Go get the parasite.
Put the burger in the bag.
Is that it?
Is that everything?
Conserved?
It's a weird sandwich.
That's not the right thing.
Oh no, you fucked up the order?
Oh, donkeys!
We fucked up.
You mean you put the things on wrong?
Cause you lied about lettuce!
Why would you lie about lettuce?
That's such a weird thing to lie about.
I am looking out for the customers.
I don't want people that have diarrhea parasites.
I am a fucking deer.
Did you put the lettuce on?
You put the lettuce on.
That's good.
Yeah, I put the lettuce on.
And now, mayo.
You put some mayo and a top bun.
There you go.
Just like the first burger I made.
Burger, burger, burger, burger.
Burger, burger, burger in here.
All right.
Next door.
That is wonderful.
Bigly, pigly.
What do we need?
All right, I put some bottom ones.
Salmon nuggets.
I can, I can.
make the burgers if you want swimmers try if you want to
concentrate on burning out yeah i'll make the burgers i'll
make the burgers i'll make like bigly bigly trust me she
took over my burger job i don't trust you i don't think
anybody should trust you it's either it's either take over
your burger job or watch you make burgers it sounds really
boring can i have a pork patty is that a pork patty oh my
god oh my god it got immersed in the cheese it's right here
it's right here i got the pork patty there you go okay i'm
gonna get some cheese then you're doing my job Oh my god.
Oh.
I mean, if you want to put the meats on the burgers, that'd
be great, because I can't tell what's fucking what, because
it's all over the goddamn floor.
The 50 burgers on the floor indicates not a good job.
I'm gonna say it.
You don't know shit.
You're so brave for saying it.
This is way more antagonistic shit than the last one.
I don't know what you're even doing.
I'm fighting the paranormal right now.
Bigly, bigly in the bag.
Because I've got a drink here.
Do we got the nuggy?
We good.
We're great.
Yep.
Fantastic.
Good job, everybody.
Burger, burger, burger, burger.
Burger, burger.
Burger.
Okay, okay, okay.
I got the chicken.
That's a bit.
Wait, Snuffy.
Where are you?
I need lettuce.
Lettuce goes on here.
I got chickens.
Where did you find the salmon nuggets at?
Oh, it's in here.
This is the bottom one.
Okay, okay.
I got the beef.
That's poor the beef
She's got beef she's got me you she's pushing she's pushing
okay beef cheese cheese Who is who is holding the building?
Can I help you?
Oh, my gosh.
onions.
Pickles.
You need chicken.
I have chicken right here.
I do not need chicken on this burger.
Who needs chicken?
Mame.
I need chicken there.
Hot one.
Done.
I'll make your burger here.
I got the chicken right here.
I'm good.
I put the fries in the bag.
Where's the bag?
Bagger burger in the bag.
Okay, we just need a mother clucker.
I'm assembling.
She's assembling.
Patty.
Okay.
Oh wait, no, that's the wrong thing.
Don't worry, I'm making more chicken.
Mother clucker.
I'll keep those there.
It's doing so good, guys!
I think one of us is gonna get promotion!
It's not gonna be you yet.
A ghost just stole my fish.
Oh.
Sorry.
Well, I was fighting the paranormal.
But now I'm assembling the mother clucker.
I'm doing- I'm entertaining the customers with dance and
song.
Oh, she's dancing.
Wait, Min's not doing her job.
Oh dear.
What's that mean?
Oh, that's fine.
It's just the paranormal.
It's just Min inviting her friends over at the party.
Do you think I have friends over to invite?
You got this.
Is that a mother clucker?
Get out of my way everybody.
Get out of my way.
She assembles one burger.
She thinks she's God.
Yay!
Customer's waiting.
What's the next one?
We're so good.
I'll do the mother clucker.
I'm doing the mother clucker.
I'll get the menu.
You get the dairy fairy.
And I'm gonna jerk off in the break room.
Sounds good.
Doki bird has assaulted a customer.
Dairy fairy.
What did I do?
Wait, I've never made a burger before.
Is it hard?
We got a lot of people in mind.
Oh, it's not too bad.
Where's the chicken?
Mustard?
Do we have chicken anywhere?
Yeah, we do.
It's on the floor.
Oh, these tomatoes.
I don't know what you're saying, but.
you don't know i do not see the chicken here do you did the
ghost eat the chicken again i need the ghost eat the chicken
the ghost really like chicken one two three bacon beef bacon
you're having the chicken now i need a beef i need a beef
right now it's on the floor it's on the floor is that a beef
right there i got chicken right here oh it is it is oh my
gosh chicken chicken they're all on the fly this one this
one Very, very, by the way.
And then I want...
Bacon.
Are you bacon?
Did you do bacon?
Yeah.
It's right here.
Oh, does that not eat cooking?
It doesn't eat cooking?
Fantastic.
Okay, cool.
Wait, I made a weird sandwich.
What do I do with it?
Throw it in the bin.
You fucked up the sandwich?
Tomato.
How do I mess it up?
Nickel.
Yeah?
You forgot to put three cheese, did you?
No, I did put three cheese.
You forgot to put three cheese?
No, I didn't.
I didn't Oh shit, do we close up rolling out there?
Wait, we should close up!
No, we don't we don't we haven't made our quota yet, I don't
think Yeah, but we have so fireworks I saw fireworks.
I think we met it.
No, I have to go from the bottom up.
Three cheese.
Quota not met?
Oh shit The dairy fairy needs to go in there.
I'm working on it.
I'm working on it!
You don't don't!
No!
No, I'm out of my way!
Onion and mustard.
Boom!
I got the mustard.
Put the onions on.
Mustard and then top bun.
Oh God, oh geez.
Dairy fairy!
Everything's floating.
I'm trying to keep it.
Oh my God.
Oh, we got it, we got it.
Wait, where'd the person go?
We should, we should, we should leave.
We should leave.
Order waiting at the lobby.
Can we close up?
Do we have multiple days or we just fucked?
I think we, maybe we have multiple days guys maybe right but
I can't push this lever I don't know about you oh let's okay
maybe if we take one more art order we might be able to make
the quota jungle I got the jungle cola freeze why did Doki
assault the customer what did I do I don't know I don't know
I keep yelling at you it might it might actually attribute
everything to Doki it might that mean it might be what it's
doing someone else I think she's liable I think she's liable
I think somebody is Baby snuffy assaulted a customer.
I've never, I would never, I would never.
I did not do that.
Oh, wow, it was you.
It sounds like a good Sumeritan.
Are you kidding?
What the heck happened?
You wanna go?
Yeah, I do.
I do.
I'm the manager.
Yeah, I do wanna go.
Wait, you're made.
Wait, you're giving me a concussion.
I need chicken breast.
Did you get this?
I got too many watermelons.
Is it raw?
It's raw.
No, these are...
I think they're uncut lettuce.
Stop saying no like that.
I think one of the guests is a ghost.
They keep lubricating the chairs.
I need to like... It's gotta be this guy.
Get out of here.
The simulation?
Uh oh.
Oh, uh oh.
Okay, okay, okay.
Turn off the kitchen appliances.
Uh, extinguish fire.
Okay, I'll do that.
Jesus Christ.
I got the fire.
I'm doing fires too.
I tried to do it.
Fire taking care of.
Calibrate thermostats.
What the?
There's a thermostat.
Turn off kitchen appliance.
Did you get instantly flicked onto your donkey?
I sort of, I was really proud of myself for helping me,
helping extinguishing fires.
And I walked into the monster because I was very proud of
myself.
No, please let me go home!
Let me go home!
Wait, stop it.
Oh, we died.
Alright, so we got everything, but...
I just realized I've been streaming an 8k.
Hold on, wait.
What?
Ow.
Dang it!
You like pushing people while there is Okay, okay, let's go.
It's me!
I'm the employee of the week!
Okay, wait, I'll be right back before we start.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay, all right, stuff.
Wait, while stuff is fixing it, we go to the arcade, guys.
Let's go to the arcade.
We have no...
Oh, we have a little bit of money.
We can blackjack.
Okay, are we...
How do we have money?
We died.
You're in?
I'm...
Wait, you used up all our money.
No, I didn't.
Yes, you did!
I can't go in!
Oh.
Hit.
Why are there 20 stages on this fucking grill?
Oh, you got it!
Weird.
Yo, you lost it.
Alright, well, Min lost us lost all our money.
I'm in?
How do you still have money?
I had $66.
Who gave you $66?
Because I'm a good worker.
Oh yeah, for sure.
I'm standing.
Did I win?
Stop fucking gambling our money away!
But at least do something productive like betting on horses.
Don't tell me what to do with my money.
I'm gonna go with Chief Spaghetti.
All in on Chief Spaghetti.
Oh, do you guys hear Skibity Riz won the next horse race,
the last horse race again?
He did!
Yeah!
Skibity Riz is a two-time champ.
How does it go?
Oh, they're off!
They're off!
Chief Spaghetti!
I bet everything on you, please!
Yeah, third place.
You're bad at this.
Talk bad about my horse again.
Yeah, you're bad at that.
That's right.
Yeah.
You lost every...
All right, bet on...
Bet on another horse.
Okay, I will.
I will.
Wait, I got knocked out.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna die much.
Oh, wait.
That's Steve.
I don't want to be...
Where's spaghetti?
I'm coming.
Back to back, skibbity-ris.
What's up?
Apparently, you push each other too long.
Push each other too long.
You get...
You get daze.
More daze.
So it's you got an energy energy bar.
Oh, sorry.
Pushed me against the wall and got me dazed earlier.
Sorry.
I didn't mean to.
I have one dollar.
You guys, look what I found.
Whoa!
This is how a lime move snaps.
Perfect gambling.
Set it all on fire, lime move.
Set it all on fire.
Let it all do.
No!
This is what minimum wage work does to her.
This is what Doki Bird does to her.
What do you mean?
What did I do?
No, Blackjack!
Please!
Guys, guys, I think this time we got this.
Oh my god, you killed a man.
Yeah, I pushed that guy and he died.
I don't know.
He stopped shoving me.
What did you- This guy!
Doki Bird injured toe, apparently.
Why did you do that?
Fuck that guy.
Fuck that guy in particular.
I gotta smoke before my shift.
Alright, guys.
Are you guys ready?
Almost.
I got my nicotine high.
Okay.
I want to play B-ball real quick.
Wait, where are you?
Is this me playing B-ball?
The fire extinguisher is just...
Expelling fire everywhere.
We're bawling.
I'm in hell and you guys are bawling.
We're just waiting in hell.
I'm just expecting you to win.
Hey, stop!
I'm trying to play it again.
I wasn't even playing against it.
One, one, one, one, one, uh, one, uh, one, uh, zero.
I can't count.
One, two, one, one, one, two, one.
Oh, two, zero.
One, Z, one, one, B, one, two, one.
I'm having a stroke right now.
She can only play basketball, guys.
She can't do anything else.
Come on.
We're just scoring a shot.
We're waiting for you.
I'm trying.
I'm holding on.
I get it.
I am.
We're waiting for her.
We're waiting for you.
You are there, too.
Yeah, but I already won.
Look, I helped her.
I helped.
I was hoping her win.
But get over here.
We have to start our shift.
Oh, my.
She can't stop bowling.
I can't stop.
Is this the whole?
We are stuck in hell.
I'm taking this with me.
Oh.
We're at risk.
I gave her an assist.
All right.
We got this.
We just, we almost figured out how to close shop.
We're becoming more.
Oh, I don't like those things.
I don't like it.
The, oh, what do we got today?
The tow is taxing everybody now.
All shop items are doubled.
Wait.
Well, that is, we've never even gotten to use fucking shop
items.
So whatever.
Order timeouts have in.
customers arrived 30% let's go for the tariffs then since we
can't buy anything yeah because we yeah we genuinely have
not even got that before so snuffy are you are you like kind
of like organizing the uh customers and keeping the chaos
from going crazy out there because it seemed like that was
what it was wanted you to do i don't even know i don't know
how to okay so somebody stopped the haunting but i don't
know how assaulting somebody definitely it definitely wasn't
me we have to maybe we just assaulted the spooky ones there
are employees that look weird oh you're Oh, okay.
Alright, I got the burger.
I got you?
Little bee.
Strawberry jacuzzi.
I'm gonna put this here because it's always gonna need that.
Okay, one little bee.
Yeah, one little bee.
One little bee.
Making a little bee.
I got the strawberry.
I need a beef patty.
Me on the floor.
Please don't put it on the floor.
Where else do I put it?
Actually, it's not a bad strat though.
It's not a bad strat.
Yeah, I don't think it's a bad...
Do you have beef yet?
There's beef.
Okay, cool.
Me on the floor.
Cheebs.
Top one.
Boom, boom, boom.
I got a little bee.
Little bee in the bag.
Little bee in the bag!
Oh, wait.
It's good.
It's done.
Put that out there.
Why are you throwing it all on the floor?
How can I help you, sir?
I feel like we don't need... It's so hard to trick down what
we have.
That's sufficient.
Where else am I supposed to put it?
You're making a spill.
It adds up later.
I need chicken.
Why do I stop?
Close this.
That's making everything cold.
Now it's on fire.
No, no, no, it's not.
There's a frozen spill and a fire at the- Strawberry
Jacuzzi.
Are you the fucking avatar of the kitchen?
Strawberry Jacuzzi.
The thing's on fire, by the way.
Is this done?
Oh, this is overcooked.
Oh, shoot.
We have to redo it, huh?
Awkward.
We got pepper breast in the bag!
How did you get so many tomatoes?
Peppery breast in the bag!
How may it help you today?
We are doing a good job.
Dairy fairy.
We're doing so well.
Strawberry jacuzzi.
Dang, everything is strawberry jacuzzi.
This...
Dairy fairy.
I will make the dairy fairy.
I need a beef patty.
I need lettuce.
Be fatty on the floor.
Beef fatty on the floor.
You're ruining my fantasy right now.
Beef patty on the floor.
Wait until we get tried through for real.
I'm just getting into my groove three times cheese, Jesus
Christ.
One, two, three.
Tomato.
That's bacon.
Yeah, be careful because these burnt last time.
Onion.
Yeah.
Oops.
Oh, I fucked them up.
All right, I'll try that again.
What did I miss?
I need more beef.
Oh, I'm cold.
You're not doing your job.
Can somebody turn up the heat?
I'm kind of chilly apparently.
Wait, why is there like a fire happening over here?
Am I crazy?
Oh, the restaurant is on fire outside?
Wait, cheese.
Why is it on fire?
Three.
Three cheese.
What is bacon?
I'll be cutting bacon cheese.
Tomato and cheese.
What did I miss?
this last time.
Strawberry jacuzzi.
One mustard.
Hot bun.
The restaurant is no longer on fire.
Dairy thing!
Me in the bag.
Do we have strawberry jacuzzi already?
I got it.
I got the strawberry jacuzzi.
I hate this game.
All right, next.
Order up.
Jazzy Java.
Peppery breast.
A peppery breast?
She can't.
It's on the floor.
I'm on the floor.
Oh, you got the Jazzy Jaffa.
Peppery breast coming up.
That's fish.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
That's chicken.
Ooh, that looks good.
Two bacon.
LaMow.
Pick this.
Be patty on the floor.
That's too much.
I got a cooked chicken patty on the floor.
On the floor.
Yeah, see, like, we're out of somebody else's.
Peppery breast is in the bag.
We need you.
There you go.
Nice.
We're up.
Or up.
Bigly, pigly, bigly, pigly.
Everybody's like the bouncer.
Snoopy is like, it's fighting people outside, I'm pretty
sure.
It's like the only paranormal activity comes from my hires.
I think I threw something into the void.
I'm gonna just wipe that.
Oh, there's some cheese on the floor.
Cheese on the floor.
Okay, the pork keeps phasing through the fucking burger.
I have another pork here.
It keeps going through the thing.
This is a fish patty.
It keeps flying through the fucking burgers.
Thank you.
There we go.
We're doing so well.
Mustard, mayo, top bun.
Yeah, I already got them in the bag.
I've got them in the bag.
Salmon nuggets on the floor.
I have a bag.
How may I help you?
Burger, burger, and dairy fairy.
Burger, burger, dairy, berry.
Burger, burger.
Dairy, burger.
Burger, burger, dairy, berry.
It's alright.
I'm here.
On bottom.
We're here.
Oh!
That's pork.
That's beef.
Oh, can you guys spit on?
Okay, thanks.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
Oh, do you want me to try?
Why does it have to be the exact order?
Why does that have to be in the exact order?
I know, it's so annoying, actually.
It's so hard.
Oh, nugs.
Oops, I keep throwing the nugs.
But lettuce, thank you, beef.
Where the fuck did my beef go?
I keep teleporting!
Beef on the floor, I got it.
Nugs in the fry.
I should make...
I think you're slacking a little bit.
I'm gonna go use...
I'm gonna use the other station because my beef is
teleporting over there.
Okay.
How paranormal.
Everything's fine.
for me I hear a man I push me who pushed me I think you're
hallucinating no one did I was trying to get the mayo and I
put the ketchup on we have a fire on the roof guys I don't
mean to alarm what's a dairy okay I'll make the burger don't
I'm making burger burger no I'm making burger burger I got a
movie
I think I could hide it when the demon comes nobody's making
the dairy sorry I'm on the roof I'm parkouring right now I
can do sorry I could do the dairy fairy I was I was busy
getting like yelling at Doki all right I'm doing the bird
I'm technically the model employee right now.
I will say everything is on the floor because of you I got a
funko pop He was a freaking rat.
That is you.
They don't care But I got a funko pop making what?
No, where did you get a funko pop on the roof?
It'll help us from getting exercise I'm making burger
burger.
I'm making dairy fairy I'm dancing and entertaining the
audience onions, mustard, hot blonde, boom.
Dairy fairy, coming up.
Burger burger, coming up.
There we go, we did it.
You better help you.
Agent Orange.
Well, close to the stop.
Dairy fairy.
Is anyone else seeing the money go up at all?
Where is our money?
Bottom right corner, mine still says zero.
Mine says a dollar.
Because we haven't paid, been paid yet.
Well, it's because you gambled all your fucking money away.
Oh, yeah, but how can we how can we tell what the quota is
and when we need it?
If the money never changes, maybe it's how much how many
customers we serve big or I'm making a dairy fairy Making a
dairy fairy.
Is it me?
Am I not doing it right?
You're just giving the food away for free or something
You're not even taking money.
You're just giving them food Yeah, I won't be surprised
honestly.
I have to play.
Hey, what do you mean you won't be surprised?
I won't be surprised.
Am I the problem?
I got the jungle cola for you.
I got ancient orange.
I'll do the jazzy java.
I got the jazzy java.
Oh, you got the jazzy.
You need the dairy fairy?
Yeah, we're live and we're waiting on you for the dairy
fairy.
The fucking beef is teleporting again!
We're just waiting for you on dairy fairy.
You know, maybe Nilo should be on like...
Not, like, it's...
Do you see the all the meat is clipping through the fucking
wall here?
I think he's...
I can't see it, actually, though.
I think I actually don't see it.
I think we should stop throwing things on the floor because
it's, like, freaking out the physics.
You're just a hater.
You're a hater.
I'm throwing away all of the dirty meat.
Because it's freaking out.
Why are you throwing them away?
Because it's freaking out!
Here's Joe that I'm a better employee than you.
I am going to throttle you.
I'm technically doing three jobs right now.
Are you doing one?
I'm the song sing.
Guys, Limo is not okay.
Limo is not okay.
She's hallucinating meat and...
Yeah, she's...
Yeah, he's...
There's meat floating!
The meat is floating!
Yes, the meat is floating.
Oh, wait, no, I didn't get it.
Oh, man.
What'd you do, Snuffy?
What'd you do?
What did you do?
I don't know what I can throw.
I'll give it.
I'll try it out.
What do we need?
We need a beef patty.
Yeah, there's a beef patty right here.
Beef patty.
Not on the floor this time.
Okay, I got it.
I got the bacon.
Oh, okay.
I'm going to start throwing stuff out.
Three cheese.
Okay, you can do it.
One.
You grabbed three at a time.
What are you doing?
Does anybody want to pay me?
Three.
Tomato.
I'll take you into the bathroom.
Oh my god.
What?
Whoa.
Onion.
All right, you got the mustard and then top button.
I don't like that you can't see what's already in the bag.
Is there anything?
Yes, you can.
You can see it right here on the tablet.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Oh my god.
Is this the first time where the rest of us is better in
this game than Limo?
My dog is here.
Oh, we met the quota.
We met the quota.
Jungle rule.
Wait, we didn't get any money.
Wait, no, no, no.
Let's keep doing more orders because we're doing overtime.
I'm going to try.
I'm gonna try and make a burger burger and see if it
cooperates.
Okay.
And I'm just down to coffee.
I'm ready to fucking cook.
I'm ready to fucking do.
All right, we need jungle cola.
Two jungle cola freezes.
I'm making one.
I got it.
It just, it just, it's just, it's not working.
Who's making the burger?
Uh, Lamo.
So I'm not.
Don't, don't make her do it.
Don't make her do it.
It's, it's genuinely not working.
Someone's got to do burgers.
No, it won't work.
Lamo, you're off of burger duty.
We don't even need to do this.
But we'll get so much cash.
close we should just close oh we should close and reload the
restaurant so i can fucking make things again oh i'll do
fires oh oh i just threw the thing at the fire oh oh there's
there's little brains rolling around you guys be careful
that's normal am i turning things off yeah turn off yes
check this out my basketball training guys my basketball
training this is why this is why i play oh my The brains,
the brains, the brains.
Trash disposal?
You could call me.
Like, this is crazy.
We gotta figure out how these work.
Where's the thermostat?
I'm trying to take out the trash and it's right behind me.
I'm on fire!
Someone's not!
The thermostat?
What is the thermostat?
Guys, it's camping me.
Oh, I got, I got one of them.
I got the thermostat.
What's the thermostat?
I'm trying to do the trash.
That looks all.
I got a thermostat.
I did the trash!
That doesn't matter.
Oh, big cows here.
Big cows here.
Okay, I turned everything off.
I turned everything off.
We just need the thermostat.
I'm trying to find the last one.
I got one of them.
Oh, I got one.
Oh, wait.
No, that's not it.
Wait, where's the fire?
The fire's still.
I don't know where the other one is.
I'm on fire.
I'm not.
Oh, here I am also with the other.
You can't see the other thermostat.
Has anybody seen the thermostat?
It glows red.
You'll know when you see it glow red.
I'm trying to put you out.
It doesn't seem to work.
I'm trying to put out the place, but it doesn't.
Whale Shucks.
I'm walking around.
Oh, I found it!
Found the last one!
Hit it!
It's like in different houses.
Why isn't it working?
I got another.
Wait, there's one more somewhere.
Ah!
Looking crazy!
What was that?
I'm finding in a house.
It's in the house.
There's one here but I don't know how to turn it off.
How do you see what they look like?
You calibrate the number on the top right.
You see a number and you just go into the number.
Oh wait!
That's right then.
That's correct.
That's already done.
I got another one.
Why do we got so many albums?
I found them in 30 cents!
Oh come on.
I got another one.
I got another one!
I found them all!
Oh my god.
Get to the elevator.
Get to the elevator!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, escape, escape, go, go, go,
go, go, go, oh my god, he was right on your ass.
Oh my god, I know, please.
Yay.
Yeah.
All of this.
I think I need to, I think I need to, like, I think I need
to reconnect.
Also, it doesn't attribute anything to anyone except for
Doki.
Yeah, what the hell?
It's like Doki cooked 35 things and not all the money.
Look at that.
I told you.
I need to I need to reconnect to the game because
everything's out of sync for me.
I think she cooked all the patties.
That's true.
I threw them all over the floor.
But yeah, I'm gonna I'm gonna reconnect to the lobby.
Could you re-invite me?
Because the game's gone to shit.
No problem.
All I'm saying, I think I'm employee of the month, guys.
I'm pretty sure.
I mean, you're also assaulting all the customers, so give or
take it.
That's the time.
I was doing my job.
You know what I'm gonna do?
with all this money?
Wait, whoa.
It's time.
It's my turn to gamba.
I want to watch you lose it all.
Yeah, how do I... Do you know how to play Blackjack?
How do I...
How did you lock in?
You click buy in.
Read.
She doesn't even know how to read, you guys.
She doesn't even know how to read.
I don't seem to be...
I need to re-invite.
I can't...
I can't join.
Alright, someone else...
Someone invite her.
I'm gambling.
I'm gambling right now.
Hit it.
Whoa!
I see...
Dad.
You lost twice the room.
How much that cost?
How do I invite?
Hold on.
I'm trying.
I invited.
I'm invited.
Okay.
Thank you.
All right.
It's just not letting me rejoin anymore.
The game is cooked.
No!
It's just sitting on the menu ignoring.
I'll restart the whole thing.
We'll find out.
All right.
I bet it on Merrimype.
How do you start the game for this one?
Woof.
Wait, man.
How do you start the Gabba?
Oh, you just bet on the thing and then it just started for
some rate somehow.
Oh, wait, wait, Miramita, it's my dog.
Yeah.
I thought it was in the game.
Wait, no!
Don't fuck off, you lost your horse sets too.
Yeah, just as badly as you did.
You're kind of bad at this dokey bird.
Oh, yeah, yeah, I'm bad at it.
Wait, who threw up?
I threw up, I just threw up everywhere.
Oh, I'm good.
No.
Did you throw him?
You threw up.
Where did you throw up?
What happened to you?
Oh my god.
You got it all over me.
I have reloaded.
Could I please get another invite?
Yeah, yeah.
I got you, Lab.
Thank you.
Yeah, it says I can spread an ailment to you.
Hold on, Lee.
Wait, what?
Spread an ailment to me?
What are you doing to me?
Are you giving me the parasites?
Did I spread it to you?
Dang, I'm not contagious anymore.
Oh, I almost had it, I think.
Lime was back!
I was back.
Did I drink like something?
Hi, I'm back.
Where are you guys?
I don't know.
Where's the virus?
I'm just drinking stuff I found off the floor.
Smart idea.
Good idea.
Yeah.
Me too.
Oh, okay.
I'm ready.
I'm gonna put my money in here so we can upgrade.
Or you could gamble.
Well, it's too late.
I put all my money.
see i'm investing in our futures unlike you guys we we
aren't allowed any money it all goes to you for some reason
yeah because you guys i've got increased money right now
guys it could be that you guys that are you guys ready to
gamble i'm going oh we're gambling we're going to hell i
don't have money let's go to hell i'm going to hell i just
smoked 10 cigarettes i don't have eight dollars i have zero
dollars i mean i feel like that's pretty accurate restaurant
simulator you just like drunk off your ass and you've had
like an entire pack before this the fucking like shift
started my inner animal playing immersively right now oh
what's our presence ability drains or oh we should do
garnish wage because we're never gonna get it wrong we work
magic gift whoa we got i got a bear trap i got nicotine i
got a first aid kid are we my dog is angry we we picked both
we have both now i think oh wait no no we just got toes
tariffs i just got 20 wait there's a first aid kit there's a
first aid kit i've got the first aid kit for us hell yeah we
have a power why does that why did the work mandated gift
include england flags i just saw them like there's a bond
here they know they know who's playing i'm gonna grab is
this oh caffeine pills okay yeah i'll hold on unfortunately
my dog cannot hear dad right now because otherwise it would
just be like you know infinite recursion of dog barking he
would right now oh yeah oh it's there you go all right are
we going oh are we starting a shift i don't know what any of
these items do but let's go i got jazzy java to go hell yeah
are you ready let's go did you just immediately yop yop yop
yop yop yop yop um instantly did you put those down did you
put those down oh my god i need both of you why did i just
get magnetized am i okay what's going on am i just am i like
am i god am i okay no you're hot let's look down i got you i
got it i got it yeah yeah i got it take your job i don't
want to take your job no you're okay do we do we do we cook
the cookies i've never seen a
with them oh we put them in the oven i bet you we put them
in the oven yeah yeah hold on i got it oh you got it you got
this i'll do the little b i'll do the little b i don't know
what the others are doing it's probably fine look um someone
put the bear trap and stuff he got trapped who was the one
that put down and wasted both of our bear traps yeah who
would have one beef burger please are these i'm grabbing the
beef burger i mean wasted it's i would say honestly they
cook so quickly i wouldn't throw too much on the grill
because like i think it was freaking everything Oh, here we
go.
We're just going.
Peep patty on the floor.
Look at the meat patty on the floor.
It's cooking.
Dang it.
Alright, I got another beef patty.
Not on the floor.
I got a cookie.
Wait, where'd the cookies go?
Over here?
In the oven?
Where'd they go?
Here.
Where?
Where's here?
We'll be in the bag.
No, that's the second.
No, they were up here and I clicked them and then they
disappeared.
Right here.
Oh, they're here.
Where?
In the grinder.
Oh, in there.
I don't know how we then pick them up.
I got it.
I just got it.
You got it?
Yep.
Okay.
See, this is why you're not employee of the week and you're
not getting promoted.
She's gonna actually kill you, I think.
Another little bee.
That's actually directed towards you.
I've been grilling and I forgot to turn it on.
Okay, I'm making another little bee.
I need another beef patty.
Got the beef patty.
Thank you.
patty on the floor oh my god it's so nice to throw a beef
patty and have it actually arrive rather than just like
blinking out of fucking positions hot fries yay oh i'm
getting a little dizzy i'm getting a little nauseous guys
somebody little b is up in the bag i don't know what i
turned on i don't know how to turn off oh what is this what
is that what did i get cheese log cheese log you all need
cheese log i do not need a cheese log thank you though It's
really kind of you to offer, but I'm good.
Okay.
Deep sea, Sammy.
Yeah, fish patty is on the floor.
Wait.
Of course it is.
Where else would it be?
Because it makes total sense, honestly.
Yeah.
Fish patty.
Fish patty from the pool.
Floor patty.
Probably a patty on the thing.
You know, I think that's why we have so many customers.
What, they've heard of our fabled floor patty?
Like the extra flavor.
Yeah.
They are kind of freaky out there, to be honest.
Deep Sea Sammy in the bag.
Deep Sea Sammy ready.
We have Grip.
What's Grip?
I already got it.
It's a drink.
Mother Clocker!
Going for Mother Clocker.
Why is that guy eyeballing me the entire time as he walked
away?
What the fuck's your problem?
I'm making burgers.
These are cute.
Oh.
Oh, hey girl.
Whoa.
That's extra service.
Bacon.
Yeah.
Oh, that's true.
cheese what being awful what are you what's ailing you
what's ailing you bacon I'm on a sugar rush I'm caffeinated
I have a nicotine bug and I'm just regular it's hard but
that means you're working you're gonna work faster I am I
mean I keep generating yeah this magic box what just
happened I think I just I think I took sandwich I wonder why
it's a weird fucking sandwich she's not apparently that
would be weird i'm gonna take the cap oh no my pills my
pills nobody would fuck with my burgers no i think i need to
go find cigarettes before i die wait i have i have a first
aid kit i need chicken can you heal my addiction yeah i have
a chicken cure of this wait i actually knew i'm gonna need
cure pills something right here wait yeah i'm so i'm
addicted i'm hopelessly addicted to the nicotine thank you i
was dying i'm having a mental breakdown
We're still waiting for a mother clucker.
We have a very slow employee.
Mother clucker is in here.
It's in the bag.
Put the clucker in the bag.
Order up.
How can I help you?
Mother clucker again!
We need another mother clucker!
Another mother clucker?
I love making mother cluckers.
Chicken patty.
I need the letters first.
I'm doing the letters!
Don't worry, I'll supervise.
A chicken, bacon, cheese.
I caught bacon.
I never want to work with them.
Don't eat them.
shut the fuck up i will find you i will why are there drinks
all over the ground guys i need to take okay donky donky
turn around yeah okay good um sauce sauce me warren uh limes
mother turkey hello turn around what's up you're not you
have okay okay mindo turn around yeah yeah i need to i'm
taking everybody's view eyes what it said something entered
the restaurant i gotta figure this out vegan surprise we're
all just stressing out at each other and then wait something
answered the restaurant like she's playing she's playing
phasbo phobia or something how do you get rid of a ghost
don't get rid of me yeah i already got the jazzy java i
already got the jazzy java i'm gonna you're so fucking slow
don't keep her oh my god i'm not i'm not You're making the
chef do the other types of work.
I already had it covered.
I didn't need you to do anything.
Ah!
I feel like we can just have like a mushroom or something.
What is this?
I'm dying!
Help me!
There's an evil drone in the kitchen.
Where is Nuffy?
Don't ask.
What is this?
This isn't a ghost?
This is somebody's electronic devices attacking me.
Help me!
Oh, oh, it actually is.
Get out of here!
I have a bed kid.
Thank you.
A hot fries.
Here take it.
Burger burger.
Okay.
Make it burger burger.
We're doing a hot pie this time too.
Lettuce, beef patty.
This one's beef.
I don't know where I got some worst teams.
Hot pie.
I got a pie.
I got the pie.
It doesn't go up there.
It goes in here, I guess.
Top one, boom, bam.
Why don't we, like, pre-make- Burger in the bag.
The pies.
I got more meat.
That's not on the floor.
I don't know why it sounds like fireworks keep going off.
They are.
I think every time we put in an order, yeah, they go off.
Oh, I see.
Oh, I'll pre-make a little...
We need a hot pie.
I'm making it!
Yo, Doki, you need to get on the same level as us.
You are hindering this operation.
All I'm saying is that someone's being really slow.
Did the entire canteen just, like, physics G-mod flip out?
No.
Our stability lowered.
Have a little bee done in the future.
Bugger, bugger.
Just make bugger, bugger.
I'll make another bugger, bugger for you.
Yeah.
I'm going to make...
It's popular.
We might we I think we actually need some beef wait.
Why is this why is this why is this ascended?
Oh, it's burned.
That's why it's burned.
Okay.
We need more beef.
Don't worry.
I got you little beef little beef Tiny beef.
Why is there a raw pie tray here?
I don't know Someone's got a really nice job Little beef.
We made this little beef little beef little beef.
I pre made it.
I pre made it Just in case That's not that's not for that's
for that's for it because that's for it.
He's staring at me really scary you guys i think he wants it
right now these are all beef his fists are about to be
clenched beef cheese tomato i'm gonna pre-make a burger
that's lettuce tomato i'm gonna make a pre-make a burger
burger pre-make a burger burger actually we just kind of
need a burger burger we need it like stat we needed it
yesterday burger burger thank you i'm pre-making burger
burger we hit our Third quota.
So easy.
Wait, see, look at that.
We're getting into the groove.
Peppery breast.
I'm making a burger burger.
Just for me, it's my lunch break.
It's not.
When did you get a lunch break?
It's my lunch break.
I don't think so.
The boss gave me a lunch break because I was doing such a
good job.
Maybe you do a better job.
You also get lunch break.
I've gotten like $1,500 million.
lunch breaks you know like that one person at every job that
just tries to say discourse by like you know spreading
misinformation and gossip like it just like yeah one against
each other peppery breast like me i'm doing my job over here
you wouldn't even know what an order is if it wasn't for me
wait wait but also what is stuffy doing what is stuffy wait
why am i spooked combating the forces of evil guys i'm
spooked why am i spooked what happened your ghost that's
what happened it's really funny spook doesn't do anything
for me because i turned on i turned on the motion sensor
sorry the motion like oh yeah yeah me too me too i turned it
on so it doesn't do anything for us oh i got it oh my god oh
my god guys i think we should close the store after the prep
i think so actually our like our simulation security just
like cratered we should close i'm closing yeah yeah there's
viruses in our simulation oh extinguish fires that's what
we're gonna do extinguish the fires oh we stock the kitchen
oh my god oh yeah you gotta restock sometimes i'm gonna
start on like a thermostats because they're okay i'm doing
the fire i got one here there's one therm oh i can ping
middle button is ping i got one of the thermostats restart
oh okay middle button is ping oh i see that one's off what
excuse me i don't know that one's off There's nothing going
on here.
Alright, whatever.
Does anybody see the onions?
Onion box?
A box of onions.
Helping with trash.
Ah!
You are not helping!
There's this...
There's stuff here!
Oh, shit!
There's a cow!
I got one of the thermostats!
I need the onion.
There's something chasing us.
Keep going, keep going, keep going, keep going.
What?
How do you find the thermostats?
I need to know.
I don't know.
It's bullshit.
Oh, I found one.
I found one.
What about the items to stock the kitchen?
There's, I found one of the items.
Oh, I found!
I found buns.
Thermostat done.
Buns is necessary.
We need the buns.
There's still one more.
I got the last thermostat.
Oh my god, wait.
Where are the, where are the onions?
There we go.
I got buns.
Oh my god, wait.
Wait, why didn't it not stock the buns?
What is that?
There we go.
What the hell?
What do you mean?
I got another thermostat.
I'm so confused.
I think it's fine, I guess.
I got a bunch of...
I feel like a reset tape.
What the hell is happening?
I'm going to die because I'm trying to stock the buttons.
It's so fucked up here.
It's so fucked up.
There's a lot of things here.
How does the restock work?
And there's like boxes scattered around.
There's boxes scattered around.
You got to find them and pick it up.
And then I got VHS tape.
I did too.
Okay, see how it works.
There's something really fucked up right outside the
restaurant, by the way.
There's a drone!
Oh!
I got cooked there's a phantom burger I got cooked we need
like one more restock onions is it the buns is it the buns
because I couldn't do it oh no we are so fucked it's just
one box we're missing a box somewhere I see it I see the box
where is it it's like you're the restaurant something has
entered the restaurant that's terrible there's two boxes in
the restaurant But it's not what we need.
We gotta restock the onions.
Well, that's the only box I see.
But it's highlighting the onions.
Oh.
There's another box in there.
I don't know what that box is.
Closing time sucks.
Evidence!
Hurry up!
I cannot do it.
There is nothing.
What?
No, I looked everywhere.
I did not see pickle box or oven box what the heck did we
all die we did we're the worst we're the worst of this fuck
off okay
yeah stuffy's the employee of the way i couldn't find the
onions i don't feel like the boy why is the why is the
cleanup so hard like the whole game is crazy until it's like
nothing happens and then cleanup hits and it's just i know
we are like split up the duties what has to be bait i i can
do i can do last round last round i i got one more i got one
more lg lg let's go
to finish one shift yeah we did though remember why is dad
so mad i don't know i think he wants food all right you guys
do your work i'm gonna feed him i'll be right back hold on
okay
you know we should have a really nice and productive and
calm shift now that doki's not here so much it's so quiet
now it's so quiet here i'll just punch her into the corner
i'll put the shovel in there okay start your shift with a
quarter of your field it was a good one or a terrible one so
i picked the one that was like yeah you get stuff done okay
okay wait was a quarter of your quota is that what it said
it said like our quote the night shift is very efficient so
our quota is already parked out of this stuff that i drink
in the lobby is still affecting me dairy fairy dairy fairy
okay oh no god oh god what the hell i fired you oh my god
she's back
she's back it would have been terrible without you i know
i'm so good at cooking yeah the manager re-hired me they're
short staffed yeah immediately threw a chicken into the
bacon they're all i they have okay let us be oh we both got
fries oh no double fry we're double frying let's go it's hot
i'm generating free food also i reapplied with a new name in
the We didn't background check, so it was pretty easy.
It was a hiring event on the spot.
What do you mean?
Short-staffed me, Daryl.
What does that mean?
A lot of patties ready.
Oh, this is potato sticks, isn't it?
Dang it.
There we go.
Why did the drink machine just explode?
It adds flavor.
All right.
Everything adds flavor.
That just needs a cola, and we're done.
Cola.
Oh, I got the cola.
It's already there.
Oh.
Is it?
It doesn't say it is.
Yeah.
Oh, there you go.
Cool.
Mother Clocker.
Alright.
Oh, there it is.
That looks like chicken nut beef.
I can tell they're just...
Salmon nuggets.
Fuck.
Gotta put more nuggets.
Game sucks.
Alright.
When you have mother clocker and salmon nuggets.
Did you burn them snuffing?
Yes, how dare I was on them.
I like them extra crispy.
It should be a preference.
That's so true.
Double fluffing.
You know if it if something gets burnt, there's more you
raise the chances of getting cancer.
Oh shit.
I've been I burnt them too.
I burnt them too.
Oh.
Mother clucker in the bag.
We have no nugs.
Don't stop it!
You burned them!
I love working with my co-with my burger workers.
I love working with my sisters.
We're having a good time.
We're sisters and we're so fun.
It's very close to actually having a sister.
Burger, burger, burger, burger!
Burger, burger, making a burger burger.
I got the burger burger right here.
burger i have the burger i'm making the jungle cola thank
you i'm making the did you just spit on my burger no but i
did it now and that's okay tomatoes people pay a lot of
money that looks gross actually do it do it do it oh whoops
which one's the spit do not shove my burger thank you oh
that's
Thank you.
Dude, there's permanently like white spit all over this
shopping point now.
Burger, burger, burger, burger!
Burger, burger, burger!
It's our hot item.
And fried.
I'm putting my burger on here.
Do not put a burger on there.
I'll put my spit on there.
Do not put another burger on there.
Oh, whoops.
I want to spit right here.
That's so much spit.
That burger is like 90%.
I'm pretty sure I want I want that one yeah I pay extra for
that burger burger going in extra seasoning what's next
bigly pigly bigly pigly coming up so many pigly piglies
piglies piglies I'm gonna pre-make one burger don't do it I
how daring of you you're so brave So brave.
You're so brave.
How could you?
Bigly Pigly in the bag.
Oh, dang.
You're fast.
Thank you.
Oh, she's getting better.
We're doing it!
Oh, overtime!
It's almost as though having to like scrabble around for
food on the fucking floor makes it slower.
Dairy fairy!
Dairy fairy coming.
I got Bigly Pigly coming up.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, man.
Did somebody want that?
Onion.
and the team is locked in.
Must it.
I'm scouring the premises, making sure everybody's behaving
at the burger joint.
Yeah, you should, you should.
I got one bigly pigly.
If we ended now, will we get tons of like money?
If we, oh, something has spilled.
Oh no!
I didn't do that.
Ah, we need a broom.
I'm greasy now.
I got it, I'm, I'm, don't be buying the broom.
I cleaned it, I cleaned it.
it i cleaned it hey i'm just a little i'm a little greasy
now excuse me oh no you gotta be a chowry breast wait i have
okay where did my bigly pigly go the one i pre-made oh it's
right here i got like blown up by paranormal shit again are
we all right i'm gonna make i love this cat chicken bacon
bacon bacon bacon bacon i'm gonna make someone could make
cookies and pies that'd be great oh that's true i got pies
i'll make a pie i got cheese that free press in the bag i
don't have to get it one by one i can stock it up in my
inventory yeah did you know that yes yes we don't do that
don't be employee of the month i know right my god doesn't
even know the basics of using your hands and feet to prep a
meal like if we yeah but i'm the one that got retired for
overtime did like if we end as soon as we hit quota does it
make closing easier i was wondering that oh i'm spooked i'm
spooked it didn't really seem to now i think we spit too
much on the tablet guys my bed me too oh those are bird
droppings actually mother clacker mother clacker all right
mother clacker coming up
hot fries I need some chicken so many fries I got chicken
for you thank you did you just did Min just disintegrate no
I'm here do you see me okay okay no it looked like for a
second you disintegrated it's paranormal activity again oh
who set me on fire why did you do that no you stood on fire
literally saw you step there's a fire right below you I
can't see the order screen.
On you, sickles.
Where's the paranormal?
It's lots of hot fries.
There's hot fries in here.
I got the hot fries already.
Yeah, yeah.
You blob aqua.
I got the blob aqua.
All right, we're done.
Oh, the simulation's about to explode a little bit.
I'm closing, I'm closing.
Close, close, close.
Get ready, just close.
Get ready, get ready.
All right, all right.
What are we doing?
What are we doing, team?
Maybe we should like turn things off.
Reset the rat traps.
What the hell is that?
I see one.
I'm resetting.
Okay.
I got a grease bucket.
What did I do?
Restock the kitchen.
Oh shoot.
I got another mouse trap.
Where does the patty box go?
Okay.
I got a lettuce I got a lettuce box.
Oh the monsters are coming.
Monsters are coming.
uh do you see rat traps anywhere it's on the floor it starts
glowing i have a lettuce box here then go put it away
there's a grease bucket what am i supposed to do with the
grease oh you dispose it you dispose it yeah oh okay okay
i'm disposing i got raw fish uh where's the fish lettuce
lettuce fish goes in here oh my god okay oh my god
thermostat thermostat oh my god looking a thermostat there's
brains there's brains can i push the brains i mean you could
try i grabbed it i grabbed the brain was that fixed oh yeah
where's the thermostat i got one of them i got one of them
oh fuck me jesus christ i got one we need one one we need
more more thermostat more i got it that's bad noise that's a
bad noise Run!
My god, I lived!
How did you guys find the thermos?
I took out physics glitching all over there.
Oh my god!
I got that physics!
I didn't realize it was fun, Kathy!
Yippee!
$76, baby!
Yay!
We made money!
We did, guys!
Great!
The actual last game, we actually did it.
I'll never go to gamble.
Yeah, last game's always best game, man.
We did it.
We guys gotta take them out, invest in the restaurant.
Yes!
Investing, investing.
Investing in it!
Whoa, whoa!
We're here too!
Whoa!
Burger Chan!
I wanna be Burger Chan!
We can change our masks now.
We can do a pizza slice and a new noise pack.
Hell yeah.
I get to be spooky.
I got a cape.
I went to rock the warehouse and all I call me is this lousy
cape.
I got a bird.
Uh-huh.
Wait, how are you doing the sounds?
There's a preview.
Oh.
Where am I?
I'm stuck.
Just push me out of here.
I want the cat noises.
Yeah.
were you were you bodily function yeah bodily function
bodily function yeah i know like in like there's more
gambling now oh look you could buy pizza oh but i i used to
buy money so wait wait mint has money still no i you told me
to invest you told me to invest i invested i invested oh my
actually it didn't let me have a choice of whether i wanted
to just leave the restaurant and invested yeah i believe in
the restaurant too guys i was i think we should we should
play another we should we should do a rerun of this next
time guys oh no wait wait there's a okay have you guys saw
the the post office game with the cats no we should play
that it just came out i found out that uh it's multiplayer
and we run a post office.
I always like to run a post office.
There's no burgers there.
Yeah, I don't want to run a post office.
No more recipes.
There's no burgers in a post office.
It'll be great.
We should run a post office together.
Okay, we do that.
The sloppy sisters lick it on your stamp style.
What?
We're expanding.
We're expanding to franchise.
We're going to do this.
The sticky sisters.
Yeah.
I don't know about that word.
The stampy sisters.
We're sticky and we're sloppy.
I like the sticky sisters.
The sticky sisters.
Because we're sticking the stamps on.
Yeah, yeah.
We're expanding our business.
We're going into mail now.
We're going to Amazon.
Then we have to find an appropriate illiterative name for
every business we go into.
Oh, hey!
You pushed my beer out of my head.
It's okay.
I have cigarettes here.
I don't want cigarettes.
I don't want nanias, folks.
higher jump when i'm smoking very good yahoo oh i had a
great time working with the sloppy sisters who is as
stressful as a word yeah i'm sorry i couldn't stay longer i
have to be awake at six hours that's okay have fun have fun
thank you go to sleep go to sleep go to sleep love to all of
you
Bye-bye Bye-bye Bye-bye You think we can do pull off a run
without Labu or do we need her?
She did like all the cooking so that means it would be up to
you She do the cooking she do the clean and I don't think
any of us could do the closing by ourselves I'm like good at
customer service.
That's true.
How fucked are we we try to close?
Let's do it.
Let's do one run Let's try one round.
Let's see how...
No way!
Let's see how much she carries us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm curious.
How much is she the carry in this office?
We haven't even...
I didn't even live the last game.
We still...
That was still a win.
There's no way.
Yeah, no, men lived.
I lived, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
All right, well, we got...
Oh, we got some presents.
We woke up angry today, Joy.
Oh, wait, that's...
No, we shouldn't...
That's the closing cow.
I feel like we should get the terrorists again.
Okay, yeah, I think so too.
I don't even know what the shop is.
Wait, we get the pizza!
Check this out.
Oh, that's a long shlong.
We got gifts again.
Oh, shit!
Okay, wait, we need those because there's a test.
Beer.
And then I got the nicotine here.
I got a bear trap.
Alright, we ready?
Yeah, let's go.
Wait, we have a map now on our iPad.
What?
Wait, we have an iPad?
Yeah, you press tab.
Why is this for?
What was this for?
All right, I got...
I got the...
Bigly, pigly, pigly.
I'm making the patties.
Someone start making the burger.
It's all you, Snuffy.
What do you mean?
What do you mean, making the patties?
That's the how you make the burger.
You gotta make the burger now.
I'm making the fries.
And I'm making the patties right now.
I'm cooking the patties.
Okay, what's the burger?
What's the burger?
We're so cooked.
We're so good.
Pigly, pigly, pigly.
Okay, we're so good.
No, no, no, we got this!
Okay, okay.
She can't be 90% of the sloppy sisters.
Surely we'll have a bigger percentage.
Tomato.
It's like, you know how when a part of your brain dies, the
rest of the brain, like, picks up the slack.
Monster.
It's like that.
I feel like my mom just left me somewhere and I'm not happy
with it.
What do you mean?
We did it!
We got an order!
How can I serve you?
Swimmers choice!
I have the fish right here!
Oh, dairy fairy!
Sorry, dairy fairy!
Dairy fairy!
I have the... I have the patties!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Why do you need two drinks, ma'am?
She's so thirsty.
Maybe his girlfriend.
Maybe it's for his girlfriend.
You know?
He's like, I want a salad, but we don't have a salad.
You still want a salad right now.
Trust me.
We are definitely in the United States.
You don't want a salad right now.
This could be Australia.
I don't think so.
They were these portions?
No.
Yeah.
They call it the great outback.
That's what they call me in the club.
Oh my god.
I forgot we had a new location.
I forgot about that.
Oh yeah we did.
Yeah.
What?
Did we get everything?
Did you get it off?
Did you make the dairy fairy?
Oh, Snuffy!
It had it all!
Snuffy!
We lost so much simulation stability!
Come on, Snuffy!
This isn't what I got hired for.
I was hired for janitorial duty.
Yeah, and then Lamo quit!
Beef, patties, there's pork and beef.
Wait, where's that?
I didn't know there was beef and pork.
What do you mean?
Okay, all right, Stuffy.
Oh, geez.
Stuffy, I think you might be our worst employee.
I'm taking and you're worse than me and that's saying
something.
Oh my, oh my.
Oh, is that I'm making?
Who wants pork?
Pork burger?
That's not a thing.
Oh, what do you mean I've never had?
Wait, I'm chilled.
What's a pork burger?
What's pork?
Oh, what the hell?
This thing just spat out.
This thing just...
I got a dairy fairy.
Dairy fairy coming up.
That's not what we had.
So much choice is what we had.
All right, we got it.
Vegan surprise.
Fire, fire, fire.
I can make a vegan surprise.
Fettus.
That's what they call me at the club.
Lettus.
Wait, this is onion.
What did I do?
Oops.
I don't think anybody's...
Okay.
Okay, okay, all right, so get up, get out, snuffie, snuffie,
snuffie, get out.
But it's a vegan surprise, I don't even need to know what
animal it comes from.
Can I use it?
We do.
Okay, I'm cooking the...
You want some pies?
You need some fix-a-pies?
The sweets.
Pickles, mayo.
Just don't leave them.
I got the vegan surprise.
Vegan surprise!
Coming up!
We need a jacuzzi?
Nope, I already got it.
Mother Clucker!
Coming right up!
And then a chicken patty.
I'm gonna put the fire out.
Don't worry, guys.
We're gonna prove Lyme wrong, guys.
We can function together.
I thought you said fuck shit together.
Like, dang.
Well, that's maybe what we're doing.
No, we're functioning without Lyme.
This is life without Lymu.
This is what it's like.
Life without Lymu.
I feel like I'm not wearing shoes.
Mayo, hot sauce.
I need a mother clucker.
I need a mother clucker stat.
I got mother clucker coming up.
Thank you very much.
There you are, ma'am.
Thank you for coming to Floppy Sisters.
Something entered the restaurant.
Burger, burger, burger, burger.
I'm gonna go fix that something.
good at she is so good at that okay burger burger burger
burger burger oh that's the lettuce wait where's the what is
this thing get out of here you don't belong in here what is
it what is it i'm so curious what happens i got it i got it
it's that old drone oh it does show up you're gonna start i
started drinking okay but we need the burger burger we need
the burger we didn't start pre-gaming i'm pre-gaming we're
already gaming this is the game There's no pre.
This is the game.
I'm pre-game.
Make the burger, dokey.
I am.
It's been 30 seconds.
She's going to collapse of starvation.
God, I hope so.
I pick us.
You know who was really fast at making the burgers?
Limeo.
Oh, yeah.
Well, she's dead.
They got her.
Burger burger.
Yeah, they got it.
How can I help you?
Pigly, Pigly, Pigly.
Where did the fruit come from?
It might have been thrown up by the machine.
A pork belly.
Do we have any porks left, guys?
Oh, we do.
Well, guess who's in charge of that, huh?
Jeez.
Yeah, and I did have a pork.
So I'm doing my job.
And what are you doing, Stuffy, huh?
What's your job?
um slacking the f off because i'm cool as hell all right
pigly pigly done what if i say you're not cool huh i found a
cassette i found john though i don't need your validation
that's what makes me cool did you serve the order why didn't
you serve it no that's not my job that's what you're hired
for i'm here making burgers uh burger burger burger burger
uh You know, this would be the perfect time to pre-make a
thing, you know, that you were so brave to say that you
would do before.
Yeah, and that's what I'm doing right now.
Pre-making patties right now.
Are you pre-making the burger burger that we need?
Yeah, pre-making it right now.
Snuffy, I have to pee.
You have to take over my job.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
All right.
It's probably hard.
Jazzy Java.
You gotta get the Jazzy Java.
I already did that.
Hurry up the F-O.
Come on.
I'm already making the next burger.
onion mayo pickle pickle you put mayo already why did you
put the mayo over the it wasn't there wasn't that was my
spit that wasn't the mayo you just literally i i saw i saw
the tablet the pad tablet said that oh my god and i go go
make up go make a patty go make a bee patty right now who's
making all that thudding noise oh it's an evil what is that
what did he just do he's dropping bombs hold on i gotta go i
hope he bombs this restaurant oh my god no no not on my
watch wait no never mind he's out of here okay well there's
just like bombs around so don't worry about that wait what
why is there bombs around um i don't know what do i do with
them i don't know what to do with these put them in the
garbage oh i fucked up again oh oh okay so so you blame me
the last time and that was oh stuffy me up again i'm dealing
with the freaking bombs i'm throwing them away the keys
where did this fire start tomato onion uh pick i'm still
waiting mail jazzy java here i'm i'm done i finished the
burger burger Here we go.
Meals done.
Why is your floating fire extinguisher?
I don't know how to put out the fire.
I'm on fire.
You serve the meal.
We better quota.
We have to wait until Vince's back before we close up.
See?
We can make quota together.
That's the easy part.
We got it.
We can make quota.
That one I'm afraid for closing.
Dairy fairy end.
Alright, no, we gotta, Mint's gotta get, get over here right
now.
How is it going, team?
We can make quota, we made quota, we gotta go.
Oh, we gotta go!
Okay, I'm scared, I'm scared.
Kitchen, turn off the appliances.
Grease, grease.
Dispose of garbage.
Grease off the kitchen, okay.
Turn off the pot, I got the...
Oh, I got the...
Oh, off, off.
Oh, the cow's here, the cow's behind me.
I'm disposing of grease.
Oh shoot, that's, oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
No!
Where am I?
Where did I go?
You're alive.
You're alive, right?
Are you alive?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm alive, I'm alive, I'm alive, I'm
alive!
Oh, sorry.
Uh.
Shoot.
I got another mouse trap!
Uh, how do you do the mouse traps?
Do you see them on the ground?
It's red, yeah, yeah, it's, it's glows red.
I have lettuce.
I have, uh, I have, uh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I have two pairs of food on me.
Wait, oh, I think I got it.
It's coming.
I got a mouse trap.
I have two pairs of food on me.
Bantrap.
Someone, someone get this, restock the kitchen.
I have two foods in the kitchen.
I don't know what we need to restock on.
I don't see, I'm stuck.
Oh god, I'm stuck.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Did you work at the food?
I'm working on it.
Where's the stocking stuff?
It's inside.
Put everything inside.
I got it.
Oh, okay.
I did it.
Did we did it?
Did we do it?
No, there's more food that needs to be restocked.
Ah, what the go?
What just happened?
Oh my god.
Oh, wait, what just happened to me?
I just got teleported.
I got teleported to spawn.
so good luck everybody else I got a bee wait is that a
person restocking what the hell is that I'm dead I restocked
it I restocked it go go go go Go, go, go.
You have to live.
I'm coming.
It's camping, so if you're not in there, yeah, it's spawned.
How do I make it go?
It's gone, it's gone, it's gone.
What the?
We all died.
No.
Wait, how do you, guys?
Wait, where do you, how do you live?
What's up with you?
Guys, see, guys, see?
See, we can survive without lives.
I moved.
Barely.
I was so close!
Dang it!
I did it!
Employee of the week.
Don't worry.
I hate this game.
I don't want to play anymore.
I quit.
I quit this job.
Wait, but what if there's a new location?
I never got to gamble.
It's not worth it.
Nothing is worth it if I don't even make money.
It's okay.
The house always wins.
The jar to open.
Wait, how many are you going to donate?
We will.
Oh, I have to...
We need to get like, oh, I don't have enough.
It locks the new store if we level it up.
Wait, what do you mean it locks it?
Because we need to be in tier two.
We are in tier two.
Oh, we have to ascend to tier two.
We're not ascended yet.
Oh, I said we're tier one.
This is so lame.
You guys won't watch me gamble.
Who's pooping?
Wait, who is that?
I gotta go.
I gotta go to the toilet.
Oh, wait, who are you?
Oh.
I thought that was a random person in our lobby.
I'm gonna invest.
I'll invest.
I invested a little.
That was useless.
You're stupid at investing.
You don't know business at all.
You don't even know how the money works.
Oh, yeah?
Now what?
You're the one with zero dollars.
Okay, fine.
Let's not have this one with a ball.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, come on, let's settle this.
All right, first one, the score wins.
Watch this.
I'm about to take over for LeBron.
Oh, this is my World Cup.
Oh, World Cup is soccer.
Can you be NBA?
What does it have to do with soccer?
It can be a cup.
Cups have nothing to do with soccer anyway.
Oh, my God.
Can you guys just score?
We don't have a beatbox.
You just intercepted me.
I got it.
I squirt.
That was my ball.
I've lost in every game.
I've lost every way.
I have no money.
I have no ball.
I have no street cred.
You don't even have the beatbox.
You can't even beatbox.
All I have is a nicotine addiction.
Not the...
Watch this.
Not everybody's born to be a baller.
Oh my god.
First try.
Failed it.
Scored.
First try.
No you did it.
The score doesn't even go up.
First try.
Watch this.
Oh my god, I gave you an assist.
You're welcome.
No, you did it.
That was pure skill, baby.
That was pure skill.
Victory punch.
My ball literally hit your ball and then it...
Victory spit.
Oh, I'm dazed.
I'm dazed.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, wait.
That's right.
Wait, how do I... Oh, there we go.
Whoa.
That's right.
You're not safe either.
Oh, my god.
Oh my god, oh shit, sorry, I pushed you a little too hard,
stuffy.
I- Wait, it won't let me out.
Wait.
Where are you?
I'm stuck in the chat box.
W-A-S-D.
This is fun, guys.
I gotta go before I fall asleep in the burger joint.
I got GGs, everyone.
GGs!
Thank you for coming to open another franchise with me.
successful business yeah another successful business from
the sloppy sisters happy customers yeah tune in next time
when we open our post office our post oh yeah oh goodbye i
want to play one more time okay okay bye bye bye bye all
right let's watch you ball all right watch this oh wait my
game is bugged wait my game my game is bugged oh there it is
okay yeah bug no i'm for real for real my chat i'm glad i'm
streaming this i have witnesses i have witnesses yeah yeah
yeah she's lying you see right oh god how do you do the
sound oh let's see you press c i am
Why is it?
No, where's my burger tan?
Yeah!
Okay, that was mine.
That was mine.
What the hell?
Ref!
She's punching me foul!
Red card!
I heard your keyboard.
I heard it.
I hear yours too.
Oh, we can't go out there.
Wait, wait, wait.
There's another.
I just realized there's another basket.
Yeah, that's for the other side.
Oh, yeah, we're both on the same side.
We're scoring on each other.
Yeah, because we're on the same side.
Take me somewhere.
I am not.
Oh.
What do you do?
It just...
It just teleported me when I said that.
Take me somewhere I am not?
Oh!
Where did you go?
Where...
I'm at the simulation.
I went to, like, the...
Wait, but our mic is off.
I guess I can still hear us technically, right?
They're taking our data.
To observe the phrase is to invite it, to speak it is to
awaken it.
To speak it is to awaken it.
I guess it was just that oh wait what was that yeah yeah is
something walking oh no we're safe nah see nothing to worry
about yeah nothing is fine look at that we're so good at
this business stuff I know right oh my god oh my god we
should open like every type of business have you played the
gamble of your friends yet No, I haven't.
We should do post office and then we should open a casino
next.
I think we are like successful business women.
We should be like...
We're going to be like...
What are those Korean conglomerates that own everything?
Doki, I'm in...
What the fuck?
You're in the closet.
No, come into the closet.
What the fuck?
Where are we?
What is this game?
What is this?
The new Elysium City.
We're back in the closet.
What is this game?
Where are we?
What is this?
Is this like the plan to take over the world?
Like, I guess so.
Wait, there's stuff here.
Burger.
Critical threat level.
Containment.
Test subject.
Co-op pool.
Sentience fabrication.
Oh yeah.
These must be the places we could be.
Test subject E17 data upload complete.
Oh my god, there was lore.
I thought we were just doing burgers.
Of course there's lore.
Wait, this is like...
Actually, do you know the original game to this?
No, I've heard it was really popular.
Yeah, I never played it, but... Me too.
It's like a solo game, too.
Wait, what does your cape say?
I went to rack the warehouse, and all I get was this lousy
cape.
Yeah, that's what it says.
Damn.
Test subject co-op.
This is a creepy pasta.
This is an SCP.
The lore is deep.
Yeah, I heard like, it's like the...
Oh, have you got a DM from Garden of Bam Bam?
No.
Oh, the devs from Garden of Bam Bam DMed me and was like, we
love your content.
Keep up the good.
Are you going to be in Garden of Bam Bam?
I guess I got to play Garden of Bam.
Oh boy, you're going to really be good at that.
that one and you're gonna enjoy it so much.
Wait, have you played it?
I know about it.
You wanna watch me play Garden of Badness?
Oh, no, I don't because you- Why not?
I don't think you'll play it.
What do you mean a devs play?
I love your content.
Apparently I looked at their Twitter account.
They follow VTubers and stuff.
I saw like a bunch of Twitter following for VTubers.
Are you jealous?
No.
I don't know.
I'm watching Jackie the bridge burner.
You're watching what?
Where are you watching that?
On the TV.
You can't see it?
Oh.
Oh, wait.
I see it now.
Detective Jackie.
Episode one.
Sorry, reset it.
Guys, the reason I don't want to watch her play it is
because she will stand in the corner the whole time and be
like...
That's not true.
Guys!
You're a coward.
How am I the coward?
Because I'll be one playing it, but you're too scared.
like a seven hour vaude because you won't play it i'll prove
you wrong after off guy i'll prove you wrong okay before off
guy i know you understand i don't have time before off guy
yes you i saw i saw your schedule how do you know my
schedule because i'm the server i literally said i don't
even have time for the collab that that matara was trying to
set up no no i'm looking at it What?
You leave on...
You have Tuesday.
What do you have on Tuesday?
Actually, I don't remember what I have on Tuesday.
I got you.
You have nothing.
I know what I have on Tuesday.
Wait, no, I don't.
Oh, yeah.
My schedule's all messed up now because of stuff.
That's right.
I'm a bridge burner.
You're free on Tuesday.
Garden of Bam Bam.
Guys, she's such a stalker.
What do you mean it's in the public server?
It's not even public!
It's in our public service.
What is happening in this movie?
I don't know.
That's episode one.
Wait, is this... Oh my god, he's dead.
He's dead.
He's like Casablanca.
I've never watched Casablanca.
I just know it's black and white.
That's your knowledge.
Oh, they're crying.
Is he gonna come out?
Oh, he's crying.
Oh, my god.
Is that like a stock baby crab?
I think so.
What is happening?
No, he's just a funeral.
Nope.
No.
It could be Casablanca.
I'm pretty sure they're wearing Casablanca clothes.
This game has everything.
Like, what is this game?
I got the I got videotapes and I got cassette tapes and
stuff too.
While I was out.
I don't think you get soloed this.
I don't know.
This is not.
I don't think it, like, scales at all.
Your stamina runs out so fast when you're trying to run away
from the guys.
I had caffeine, so I just, like, chugged that in.
Oh, that's probably what you're supposed to do.
Yeah, I saved it for, like, that's why I lived.
Okay, well, I'm going to go now.
All right, I'll see you on Tuesday.
I'll see you not Tuesday.
I don't want to watch you play a game on Tuesday.
I want to stream on my own channel on Tuesday.
I can watch you on cheese.
I can watch you play card at bad bad.
I don't want to play it.
That's why I haven't.
Why don't you want to play card at a bad bad?
What's wrong?
What's wrong, huh?
I'll DM you.
What's wrong?
Yeah, maybe if the devs loved my content, then I would
consider it, you know?
But clearly, I suck.
That's so dangerous.
Yeah, clear.
Okay.
Bye, Doki.
Bye.
Oh my god.
Oh, I forgot how gross this menu is.
She's going to DM Doki the airplane scene.
The what?
The airplane scene.
I think Doki Bird might be obsessed with me, you guys.
What the heck?
The meat portal.
This was a game.
I don't know how Doki finds these.
I think she wanted to play it because it was...
a restaurant, and that's where our origins began, as the
Sloppy Sisters.
But...
Wow.
I felt I was a good team player today.
I think I did my very best.
I did not do well during the bits where the creatures were
chasing after you, though.
That one was hard.
That was so tough.
They're, like, suddenly, like, turned off all the stuff.
Do the thermometers.
I didn't do a single thermometer.
You danced and did nothing for half of it.
What are you talking about?
No, I...
Okay, you've never heard of too many cooks now, have you?
Someone has to be cooking the burgers.
I took the orders.
I made the drinks.
I did lots of stuff.
You're just a hater.
Who can blame Doki obsession with Minto as normal, right?
Maybe.
Mods kill him.
Mods give him the lettuce parasite.
Yeah, I did the nuggies and the fries and the cookies and
the pies.
I did it all!
Not all.
I did a lot.
And I made some burgers too.
Mods give him Taco Bell.
She got sick rhymes.
She did her time!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
You did trash basketball.
I did!
I took out the trash many times.
I did the greasing.
I did the trashing.
I did one mouse trap.
No thermometers.
Not a single one.
And I escaped once.
All of that and still danced.
I took the orders and stuff because I didn't want a dokey
bird in my ear being like, okay, now you got to do this.
Now you got the burgers on the floor.
We also know how the club can have drinks and beats, but
that ain't turnt without you ghosty, outback vegan surprise.
She's been a proper maid for once.
Praise me!
Wait, do I have a hand?
Do I have a hand?
Oh.
Yes!
Praise me right now!
Here, can you wipe off the...
Oh, whoops.
Thanks for grabbing that for me.
look into the meat circle look into the meat circle you are
feeling very hungry you are wanting patty vegan surprise
vegan surprise vegan surprise vegan surprise yes you're okay
I guess oh I don't like the music I can't I keep wanting to
close it.
There we go.
Look into my eyes!
You are obsessed, you are obsessed, you are obsessed!
And I also have a new outfit debut on Monday the 20th.
Yes, yes, yes!
New outfit, new outfit, new outfit, new outfit!
Do you guys want to see it since you're stuck till the very
end?
I'm not going to show you, but hold on.
I'll give you, I'll show you...
Hold on.
one second please I'll give you a I'll give you a a a sneak
peek since you guys stuck to the very end
one second
oh wait I also need I want to do this oh there we go you
guys stuck to the very end so watch them
watch them wiggle watch them wiggle yes watch them wiggle
wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle in
the meat wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle in the meat i'm
wiggling in the meat i'm wiggling in the meat oh wait hold
on
uh which one was it oh that's my hat i mean
it's it's obvious it's hard
I'm leaving I'm I'm